being 10 o'clock we'll open our work
session
uh and I'll start by saying I think
we've gone through enough hoop jumping
on the adequacy formula uh because we're
all dreaming about it now
we are uh so
you have in front of you
uh a document looks like this
where Mickey took all the scenarios we
talked about played them up
all the different proposals
and basically what we're doing is we're
Reinventing the governor's budget
so it's my attitude to say
let's go with the governor's budget
because that that's he's doing what we
wanted to do in the apportionment part
part on the right hand side
uh but you see
in the in the darkened column on the
front of this page
it's taking the
rates and rounding them up rounding them
off and I would take the the uh sped ell
and third grade reading and read to the
right proposal number six where it has
2100 800
and use those rounded numbers in the
column that says Governor's recommended
budget because I don't think the
governor is going to care if we round
some of its numbers
uh and I talked with Mickey doesn't make
all that much difference
uh the other item is the two percent
cost
uh education adequacy education
components
what we're going to add so one thing the
committee could consider is if you
recall the governor gets rid of the CPI
adjustment on the the cost of an
adequate education replaces it with an
annual two percent uh adjustment you
could also consider applying that to the
thresholds the equalized valuation
perforing reduced pupil thresholds is
part of the extraordinary needs Grant
otherwise those 1 million to six million
dollar range stays stagnant over time
but you could apply that so those are
adjusted to reflect inflation as well so
if we add that yep and that doesn't
change really a whole lot for
for this biennium yeah so the between
what you were saying Mr chair rounding
up the sped to 2100 per pupil and
rounding up the English language
Learners to 800 per pupil and then
applying the two percent
also to the thresholds in the
extraordinary needs Grant other than
that you're suggesting keep staying
everything else with the governors
that's where I am I've dreamed about
this enough
any any comments yeah
um
I still find that the governor's budget
provides um you know a larger boost for
everybody but there's still a great need
on the other side of the formula and I
like some of the proposals I think
proposal 60s fleshed out the most uh
where we take that larger amount that
he's giving some goes to all the schools
on the left side but then we also have
money to increase things on the the um
the right side of the formula so I
really like the idea of being able to
Target Aid to students who really really
are going to be needing it
um
in the out years huh well I mean there's
still the difference between the
governor's recommended was 4 700 as base
and I would you know propose moving it
down to the 43 or the 4200 which Lee
which gives that
um five or four hundred
um per unit to be able to move to the
other side of the formula I just think
that it's a fair way of adjusting things
for schools that are in need well that's
what this does so if you want to take a
this does the adjustments to to you see
yeah I guess maybe I was
misunderstanding when you said I'm fine
with the concept of the governor's
budget but I would like to see money
move to the right hand side which either
looks like it could either be proposal
six or any of the other proposals six
and seven
um seems to be in the range of what we
had talked about before
but if you go pick a town that you know
is is a
needy town so to speak for me and then
it doesn't make that much difference so
so for proposal we'll pick on purpose
was it proposal seven so we'll pick on
proposal seven so that does create an
extraordinary needs Grant of 122 million
dollars but there's still a 57 million
dollar hold harmless required which is
why you see Farmington
uh and they there's loss of
stabilization even at the extraordinary
needs that high it still doesn't trigger
more money to them than under current
law they would be a hold harmless
Community but this moves us away from
the stabilization model which has been
causing so much trouble and moving into
the whole harmless model which which has
um I guess a longer shelf life a more
reasonable life instead of dealing with
stabilization it gets us into another
I can't speak to the appropriateness of
it I can tell you under the governor's
proposal the hold harmless would phase
out in 10 years versus current law
all right so we had talked on Friday and
I I thought we all had agreed that um we
would look at those communities that
don't fare well and I understand the
governor's budget is 10 years really to
have things play out the way they want
to see them play out I don't think we
have ever had a biennium where we have
not changed the formula somewhat somehow
um
I had hoped when I left here on Friday
that we would at least add
to 20 million dollars in each year of
the biennium 40 million dollars total
to the left hand side I'm sorry to the
right hand side so that at least we
could begin to bring up a little bit
those tones that are getting hit the
hardest because right now it appears to
me that towns like Bedford and the more
wealthy towns are making out much better
than places like my city in Nashua uh
and some of those communities that have
really high f r numbers and and Mickey
correct me if I'm wrong but is this a
scenario that with the what this chair
is proposing would still continue
and I don't want to put you on the spot
but this without the extra money on the
other side I just don't know how we can
make the poorer towns
um fare better
so as we heard with the governor's plan
the idea would be to eliminate the
stabilization Grant replace it with a
hold harmless so essentially the whole
harmless brings the towns up to their
current law estimates so out of the new
the new money that's appropriated it's
not going to those property poor towns
that are dependent on their old
stabilization grant that is what the
chair had said this is part of the
10-year plan that the governor put
forward so you're not going to see that
in the 2425 biennium it'll start to kick
in and and if you look at I'm going to
see if I can find an example here
look at uh on page two of this handout
you see uh Belmont I'll pick on I'll use
Belmont here you can see at a certain
point
Belmont starts to get new money under
the proposals
it doesn't kick in for every town no
like Farmington for instance we just
looked over that it doesn't kick in this
does not line up perfectly with the
governor's 10-year Outlook but it's
essentially the same idea if you
replaced each of these proposals with a
biennium perhaps looking forward at some
point towns are going to start to see
increases from the governors some may be
longer than others and it's just I don't
have those projections here to to tell
you when
but you know you can see Belmont they're
pretty close so the stabilization goes
away and they pick up some additional
Aid and the other components that you're
increasing they start to see some some
more money Farmington it's it's a much
harder struggle Berlin Claremont
Franklin I think is an example if you
flip the Franklin you'll see they
finally on the proposal nine they start
to see something so that tells me that
as part of the governor's plan it might
take a couple of budgets until you they
start to see an increase but it it would
be part of that long-term plan
so I what so
I think I'm hearing then that
by adopting the governor's proposal
that
the areas that we said we were committed
to on Friday
we will not be doing what we purported
that we wanted to do
um we'd be
projecting out many years into the
future
and I have to say it's a very uncertain
future in terms of school funding we
have a lawsuit coming down the road
um and so for the poor towns they are
not going to well
with their
their numbers
are different from what they have been
as because we're coming off the 2019 and
maybe I'm wrong in my projections
but will the city of Manchester the city
of Farmington will they be getting the
same amount as was projected in the last
biennium
or are we going to be going with the
numbers as they stand now
um because it would seem that that would
draw a lesser amount of money
am I making myself clear
I think the whole harmless me says
they're going to get the same they got
last year
for 20 for 24 and 25 under the
governor's proposal the towns that
wouldn't see an increase would be would
make sure they at least get what was
projected for them to get in fiscal 24
they'll also get that in fiscal 25 at a
minimum based on their new numbers
based on the Mark is shaking his head
based on what we estimated in November
right two well we estimated they were
getting 24. that is the minimum that
they get via the whole purpose thank you
I just have two questions just to make
sure I'm completely
um understanding this so um I'm still on
page I guess I'm on page four now
um I was just looking at Fitzwilliam I
just want to make sure we're all clear
and that I'm understanding this under
the governor's recommended budget they
would receive 17 let's say thousand here
I'm sorry I'm on Fitzwilliam I just
grabbed one example so that's
my guess my point is the
um
when we're looking at proposal three
four five six and so forth that's just
for this year this biennium this is not
spinning out across years
so you can't look at this and say oh and
you know on column whatever that there's
no change that just means there's no
change if we were to take this proposal
this is not goes across time is that
right this is only 24 and 25. yeah so
that you know we don't want to look at
that and say and as if it were years
going out no these are separate from 24
25 and the numbers are the difference
between
um you know what's the 17 let's say 17
000 is
that much more that Fitzwilliam would
get under the recommended budget for
this biennium is that what the 17 is
over the current law just so
it's not what they get it's above what
they're getting
that's just to be clear we're all
and there appear to be no decreases
um a lot of it seems most of the
communities basically stay the same
but then it's going to kick in later on
we still
um as hold harmless goes down what we
don't see here is how that affects some
of the other Communities going forward
which again gives me concerns
um for poor communities
but my understanding is that part of the
10-year plan is the the right right hand
side of the formula is enriched
so I just
I'm hearing everything that's being said
and yes we spoke on Friday about moving
money from the left to the right and um
that's why we asked Nikki to prepare
these estimates right and now I'm
looking at them and I just you know got
here and I started looking at them uh
when I sat down
and if you look at the impact on Concord
Manchester and Nashua under the
governor's proposal versus proposal
number nine so going all the way to the
other end
the changes in funding for those three
towns Concord would go from three to
nine million Manchester would go from 0
to 58.
million and Nasha would go from 7.5 to
21 pretty much we are talking about 76
million dollars in funding being taken
from pretty much everybody else and
concentrated into those three Towns now
I chose the extreme numbers right of the
range just to make a point of what the
range does of what moving money does
I am
obviously not gonna go anywhere near the
far end of that range because that level
of concentration in just three towns
kind of goes against the whole point of
helping everybody as much as possible
and you know I am open to maybe a you
know
smaller amount of money being moved from
the governor but if you just look at
those three towns the impact is
significant representative Murray was
pointing out proposal six there you'd be
looking at 37 additional million for
Manchester
you know 10 for Nashua Ballpark and
you know uh Concord would get another
almost four
it's it's a huge amount of money and it
comes from every other town and my
concern is that we would be greatly
decreasing the number of towns that
benefit from it and just concentrate it
into a few
so
I mean she's trying to every town
benefits and this is all the same amount
of money that's being reproportioned but
every town benefits some will benefit
more but that's because some schools and
we're disadvantaged than others right
well poverty poverty in Nashua and
Manchester are pretty significant and I
don't have a problem with those kind of
increases
so I mean it's it's you know I know it's
significant but that's that's what
you're trying to do so and I I mean
Farmington stays the same but I I can
argue that look stabilization we've been
getting the same stabilization 2011 and
we've lost at least 300 kids I have no
problem but we're where we're at but
when we say everybody benefits I'm just
looking randomly because I was on the
Concord page I'm looking at Cornish
who's right there
they would no longer benefit if we go to
proposal four or higher and there are a
lot of other towns you know Deerfield
would not benefit anymore starting with
proposal seven all that money comes from
someone right it's a finite Port of
money that we're looking to distribute
differently and
I think it's okay to move some but I
would caution against moving too much
because again a lot of the towns that
otherwise would benefit would no longer
benefit and I want to remind you that I
agree with the overall goals but if we
concentrate the age so much we are going
to lose the support for this
you know in the house because we are
taking a lot of the towns away from
benefiting from it and people like it or
not do look at their town I try not to
look at mine
okay but I would caution against going
too far down to the right side because a
lot of the towns would suddenly go to no
new money under this and I'm happy to
well they're going to get new money not
Mr chair if I could just add a
controversy you know a contradictory
perspective to what we just heard so
what we are looking at on this on this
spreadsheet shows us the next two year
biennium by altering that formula we've
all acknowledged that so
um I think it's important to remember
that we put our finger on the scale with
the higher number proposals to try to
benefit those property
um struggling uh districts so
we aren't seeing what happens in year
three four five six seven eight nine ten
but we all intellectually know by
putting our finger on the scale that
those property tones are going to start
to rise a little bit more in funding as
as as time comes through uh as we travel
down the timeline so
when we decide to put our finger on that
scale by a lot or a little we know that
faster down that timeline those property
struggling districts are going to feel
the benefits of of us trying to Target
the aid to them faster than we would to
the bedfords the hanovers the new
castles
so that
um you know purposefully our
distribution scheme is going to help
level
the district you know how much
everyone's getting over time so while we
can't see that here we intellectually
understand that that is true that it
will happen over time
so my perspective is that when I'm
looking at you know the
the differences between a Handover and a
Berlin I my understanding is that
we may not take
a 1.9 million increase under the
governor's proposal but we would take a
300 000 increase under a different
proposal because I understand that that
Delta is going to go to another town
faster
to get those funds increasing faster
that they Hanover can do a little bit
better in in making our needs met under
that reduced
um
proposal
but we know that the towns who are
really struggling right now in our
current law and even under the
governor's proposed plan we'll see that
relief even faster and in greater number
over time and that is that is the
principle that I believed we all agreed
in in general we were talking about on
Friday that we thought we were all
agreeing with so
um you know when we look at the snapshot
of of course Manchester or Nashua and
you know places like Concord under
proposal six or even proposal nine in
the the next biennium those numbers are
larger because we know they have larger
units of students the average daily
um
numbers of those students are higher but
you know the general principle is the
same we we said that the reason why I
attire is because we wanted to Target
Aid where it was needed most so to say
that um
you know
the governor's recommended proposal is
something that we are just gonna you
know default to because we run all these
other proposals and we're not seeing a
huge significant increase for the
property struggling districts that we
were just talking about on Friday I
think that's short-sighted because we've
we understand that by pushing down the
proposal list to three four five six
seven
we understand that we can't see it on
this spreadsheet but we understand even
closer in time those towns are going to
be doing better and
um
I just think I think it's
unfortunately we don't have projections
to read for every town across the state
but you know we
I think the argument that we had on
Friday
still stands today I think defaulting to
the governor's budget
would be a missed opportunity
um
and I hope I'm articulating it well but
I think the governor's representative
I'm going to say represented that what
we wanted to do was in his it was in the
governor's budget yeah so we were
duplicating what they have already done
only we haven't seen it all we saw it
was when they made their uh budget
introduction we'll remember the the bar
charts
um bar graphs I'm sorry
so I
having not seen what happens in year
three four five to ten I'm taking his
word for it
I think the only difference between the
governor's proposal the governor's
recommended and any of these other
additional scenarios three four five six
seven eight nine is that it's a steeper
precipitation to helping those New Year
towns faster so intellectually we're all
in the state we're all moving in the
same direction it's just how faster do
you want that you know that change to
take place and you know as Mary has as
representative Heath has mentioned many
times in our work sessions you know we
we don't have the ability to change what
happens right now three years from now
we don't know what's going to happen but
what we can do to do this time is to
accelerate that change
under one of the other proposals than
the governor's proposal to get to that
ultimate goal faster
but my unders
make you correct me if I'm wrong but my
understanding is we this reflects that
change and pick a town I mean it's it's
okay Tom you have a town I have a town
I'm looking at my own Tom Conway
um under current law
gets 12 million under the governor's
recommended gets an additional 350
000 and then
that well I guess number three it it
gets a hundred thousand but then then it
doesn't get anything in these other
proposals right so
I I don't know what you'd go home and
say do you want explanation of what's
happening with Conway here like so yeah
I guess so so Conway Conway has a
stabilization Grant
the amount of getting 4 700 per kid and
2500 per kid for free and reduced lunch
in the governor's proposal exceeds the
amount of the stabilization Grant
where are you getting those numbers well
I don't I don't I so there's
the paper behind all of these to just to
see that detail would be a ream for
everyone here so that's why you don't
have it I can't I can speak to what's
happening in an individual town I can't
walk through what's happening individual
town so Conway has a small stabilization
Grant the governor's increase to base a
would exceed that so they would actually
see an increase in the governors
but as these proposals taper down the
increase
the uh it doesn't offset the loss of
stabilization So eventually Conway would
become a whole harmless town
so that's what's Happening Here you see
that cut off from proposal three to four
thank you so just just to continue the
discussion
um I hear what representative haken
Phillips is saying and I agree
conceptually with that I mean that's
what we were discussing on Friday and I
think we are all you know aligned in
terms of those goals but here's my
concern I I did run the
percentage of uh the 120 120 something
million dollars that we're looking for
in this scenario
under the governance proposal the three
towns I mentioned would get about nine
percent of it under proposal
number nine they would get 63 percent of
it just those three times and that's
really what I have a problem with I
think we do need to send them more money
but
not to the point where the you know they
soak up more than half of this it's just
too much and I think it would unbalance
things one thing that wasn't brought up
and frankly I'm bringing it up for the
record because I don't think it's
something we can solve today
is that right now the governor 10-year
plan has significant increases in the
extraordinary needs graft I mean he's
talking 50 percent of the biennium it's
aggressive increases there when we put
more money there
obviously the governor won't be able to
maintain the 50 increases because it
could start from a large higher base and
you know explore the budget so there
will need we are essentially gonna Force
this plan to be adjusted down the road
too this is outside of the scope of our
discussion right now I think we should
focus on this biennium but it's
important to mention that that will also
be impacted all those 10-year plans and
whatnot will have to be
significantly adjusted
I continue to be open to maybe you know
moving a little down from you know the
governor to the right but again probably
six or seven are a bit too far from me
just because of the
concentration of the eight to those
towns which do need the help but I think
we also have a lot of other towns that
need the help and I think we have to
find a
reasonable line where still a lot of
towns benefit but we do achieve the
goals the policy goals that we were
talking about on Friday of maybe you
know spreading this more based on need
than just based on the number of
students I I just it's just a question
of you know where we are gonna end up
and what criteria do we use one thing
that I would appreciate Mickey just
ability of this community to kind of
hopefully predict what the house may
vote on when they look at this stuff is
there any chance to add a bottom line
you know count how many towns benefit
under each of those proposals and throw
it in at the bottom of the spreadsheet
or maybe just have it there and you know
read it to us maybe after the lunch
break or
you know because when we cut that number
of towns we may lose support in the
house and I don't want to end up with a
budget that would you know be not
supported in the house because of the
tinkering with a formula I can I can do
that uh I can have that for you just
account you know if we reconvene after
if I can add you know if you're looking
at the percentage of towns that budget
this you also need to look at the
percentage where the percentage of poor
students in these towns and where those
are and that's kind of an important part
that you're missing and um so you know
that's an interesting data point but
it's not a very
informative one if you're not looking at
where the poor students actually reside
and I agree with you that we
um you know considering the extremes is
interesting to give a whole perspective
but I think if we could focus on perhaps
selecting one of these things from the
middle that would achieve within the
governor's budget the idea of everybody
getting something but also saying we
acknowledge that there are schools that
need have more need and so I'm glad to
hear you say you would consider one of
the proposals in the middle and I think
we might focus our attention on one of
those
just can I just clarify that at this
point in time we have dismissed the
concept of adding any additional funds
I that's another variable I don't know
if anybody dismissed it but we still
don't exactly know what the bottom line
is I was asking the chair please we're
talking about the 20 million each year
no I mean if we don't we're still that's
on the table are you still on the table
yeah
where would that uh make where would
that land
if you had 20 million to distribute on
the right hand side within the context
of the governor's formula so only
extraordinary needs is our targeted
Grant it would bring it up to 52.50
so the amount of the
so close somewhere between proposals
four and five as far as targeted Aid
goes
um
and I I've got I've got that I can give
you a town by town on that just so you
you can see what that looks like as well
it's probably gonna like I said it'll
it'll be a kind of a blend between the
towns that benefit from getting 4 700
will get that benefit and then some of
those poorer towns will get a little bit
more money too but like I said it will
only be it'll be somewhere around the
four or five proposal range but I can
get that for you and that and that goes
in the extraordinary what's it called
well so extraordinary needs Grant that's
the only targeted Aid component that's
part of the governor's plan so now do
the ancestors and the Concords and the
nashuas get extraordinary needs uh yes
because that's to to
this I mean I I that means that they're
well I'm I'm just saying comparatively
and I don't know if it's spitting in the
ocean or not I can print it you got a
big you're spending a billion 20 million
stuff wow
would be 40 million over the biennium
yeah
go ahead so I would say you know to add
in that 20 million I'm certainly or 40
over the biennium I'd be supportive of
that I would still and that would move
me more towards proposal three or
proposal four because I still think that
when you're in you know perhaps money
um
where did it go increasing something
um I think representative lad had one of
them had mentioned the extraordinary or
special ed which is on the left side but
you that may be getting too much uh
we're just probably going down a rabbit
hole there but um I do think it's
appropriate to lower the base a little
bit and if we added that 20 or 40
million to the other side I could you
know I'd be happy with proposal three or
four right now I'm still looking at five
six seven is maybe going a little too
far
so Mr chair
I I'm really uncomfortable right now
talking about spending down the
education trust fund because I do
believe that we're heading into a
significant recession that maybe even
worse than what the ways and means is
predicting and I I'm not gonna say that
I'm deciding on it but I'm very very
uncomfortable right now at that thought
because
it is we are already looking to increase
the funding for Education significantly
which is a good thing and it's a good
policy but going too far puts out that
puts out puts out this puts us at risk
of not being able to sustain these
levels in future bienniums and
it's not good to jump up only to come
down and zigzag all over the place so I
would rather have a measured increase
that we know we can sustain and protect
it's it's important to give you know
stability to this and not jerk funding
around all the time so I I would urge us
to be a bit cautious because
right thank you for Sharon
um yeah we I I wouldn't be too concerned
about taking down the uh education trust
fund because if it runs short money it
can go to the general fund and that's
that's the way it was designed the
money's sitting there not doing anything
doesn't help anybody
and if I can put my foot in the bear
trap
um
[Laughter]
you know they're I can just do with one
leg uh there's also you know the
possibility we have the 60 million in
the EFA and let me just you know put out
my my little chart here in my mind we
have actual students Flesh and Blood
students who are special needs who
really need help in the school now
they're there they exist their needs are
identified with the EFA I don't have any
problem with some appropriate increase
in that but um right now those are
hypothetical students they don't exist
we don't know where they're going to be
the commissioner does not have a finance
what's it called a finance fiscal note
on that he doesn't know um Caitlyn has
been doing her best and she doesn't have
any information so we have just a data
point floating out in space without any
data to support it so if weren't
comfortable with taking as
representative papovichi Mueller
suggests going down in the um the
balance we have 60 million dollars we
could take the 20 million from there to
put it over and that would still leave I
mean that I would take 30 million I'd
actually take more but I won't
um you know we have money set aside for
students who don't exist and we have
students who do exist that have actual
needs and so we could reduce the EFA
portion of it and move that towards the
students who have actual needs so that's
another possibility of where there is
money in there if we don't want to mess
with the balance my understanding of EFA
funding it's in the in the adequacy
confront of this formula
they get they get the base
that if it's forty seven hundred dollars
that's what the EFA funds are so what
we're already accounting it's not like
it's a separate budget it's in this
budget can you address that Mickey
so this this includes just Public
District Schools so they get the same
rate in an EFA but that's a different
appropriation above and beyond the
billion that you see here there's
another line item in the budget for you
it leaves the public school and draws
down the EFA it takes that it takes the
public school piece with it correct so
so if if a student is in this count say
in the fiscal 24 account and does take
up an EFA the following year there is a
one-year lag with the count but then so
the EFA would be paid in the year that
the child is in their news and school
situation the district would get a
payment because they were in the last
year's count but then that following
year that child would no longer be in
this formula right correct so I'm half
right
so
talking about bear traps
look I'm not gonna support
reducing the EFA funding it's it's a
good program and if any student in DFA
funding is found to not exist I'm sure
there will be a fraud case against the
people who try to file for a child that
doesn't exist but
I am so not talking about fraud you
cannot go down that I'm just saying that
these students have not been identified
yet but I am no way suggesting that
there's fraud so please don't do it I
appreciate it no I was just confused by
that do not exist statement but I
appreciate the clarification because
the fact that they may not be personally
identified doesn't mean they don't exist
so as long as we are agreed on that it's
a good thing that all those are kids who
live in the state and have you know
constitutional right to an advocated
equation so I'm not willing to reduce
that and you know I'm sure that we can
figure out how to DVD a large amount of
money where's
you know trying to
appropriate here for Education uh to
so how comfortable is everybody with the
so I mean it looks like
and what can we do to uh
yeah well what so what are you supposed
to do
something I I would be open to looking
at one of the proposals maybe three four
five
oh sorry what are we doing well yeah
that's correct but the ad in the 20 I
believe um Mickey said between three and
four if you add to 20 is that correct
so disregard that comment I think that
was a little too complex to what I was
trying to explain there I think if
you're gonna add 20 million you have to
decide where you want you to add 20
million from so is your base the
governor's recommended budget and then
if so do you want the 20 million just to
go into extraordinary needs and that's
what it sounds like the plan of the
motion yes
so and I and I can present a town by
town later this afternoon on that if you
want to see what that looks like
um
before the motion I would like to see
those numbers I mean I cannot vote the
only vote I can give you right now is a
no if you're asking me to vote without
even looking at the numbers okay I mean
the analysis would have to be there and
I'm not saying I will support it after I
see the numbers but I can tell you that
for sure I cannot support it without
even looking at that
and
assuming that that is not gonna happen
for the you know looking at where we are
right now I am open to again you know
the three or four or five
from this line but then it starts to get
too concentrated and you don't we don't
want to go to an extreme that's what I'm
trying to argue here not that we don't
want to help I they absolutely need the
help
but if we move if we swing the pendulum
too far to the right we are really
concentrating this beyond the level that
I would be capable of supporting and you
know
I am yes so Mr chair it sounds like
um
there are folks who are willing to
entertain a four or five um but we want
to see the numbers by adding the
additional so could we
um cease this discussion right now and
go on to the other areas because that
will help us make decisions that we have
to make because we're going to be
looking at what are the other things
where from the education trust we're
going to be spending money on
and then come back this afternoon after
Mickey runs the numbers so everybody
will have a chance to see what the
numbers look like with those additional
I might suggest that you know we're
focusing in on you know proposal four or
five that we pick a proposal and then we
could ask Mickey to say what will this
look like if we add 20 million so when
he comes back after lunch but I think we
could possibly pick on a proposal now
get that done
um we'll all be you know we'll be
somewhere in the middle and
um then we can say what will 20 million
additional for special or you know
whatever it is on the other side look
like but then we can at least move
forward on this I think there's Goodwill
towards picking one of these proposals
I'm but I'm I'm for sticking with the
governor's number
the 4700. can I ask a question yes
please
we're live streaming so he's
he is
operated very soon thank you very much
you got to turn to Michael
it's Monday
um the governor's proposal has a point
which I like and that's where the within
the differentiated Aid special education
is increased that will help the poor
Community because there is a definite
relationship between economics and a
community and achievement and um and and
f r Medicaid
so that that's that's a positive note
um but as we have said before at forty
seven hundred dollars
um unless you're going to present some
kind of a spreadsheet which shows the
how this extends out over these this
10-year period
look at all the towns in the North
country
they're all taking a shaft
and they're not getting the support in
terms of poverty like a town which I
have just south of me where their their
tax rates going up 22 percent because
the specialized students moved in but
not just that it's just the cost of
doing business is Way Beyond and
everybody's elevating up above thirty
dollars per thousand
we can't sustain that and so where the
money has to come from is either from
that education trust fund of leveling
some more into it putting more there or
from that base adequacy figure I look at
all the towns which are and initially
showing and folks on the floor are going
to look at that
and they're going to see wow Hanover 1.9
million dollars Haverhill zero
um there's a there's a huge difference
there and and so somehow I like I like
um the fnr within the governor's budget
but I also like uh four or five
uh and with some support given to the
areas that we really need to support and
that's through the extraordinary needs
Grant which is really that's the area if
you want to help these poorer towns
um
with their economic issues that's where
we have to do something with that and I
know that's going to cost more I know it
but
um
we're in a process right now of dealing
with uh various uh suits
in in the court system to that you know
with conval and valinsky issue that has
to be resolved and I know the governor
is trying through this to show it on the
left-hand side
but initially that money is not helping
where we need to help
and so we're going to get caught up with
that as well
so I I guess I made my communicating my
buoyant here that uh forty seven hundred
dollars even though it's wonderful you
know if you look at the inputs and base
costs right now
we're supporting K through 2 education
at a PTR pupil teacher ratio of 1 to 25.
grades 3 through 12 and a pupil teacher
ratio of 1 to 30.
you know that's not happening there's no
classrooms out there where 30 kids in
them in grade three
and so that difference is being made up
on the local level that's part of the
reason why you're seeing these property
taxes Skyrocket because we're we're
trying to take an old formula and crunch
it around a little bit to try to make it
work the governor's on track to doing
something here but it needs more work
from this group right here thank you
if I may thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking the question
under a
assume no new money coming in right now
forget about the you know trust the
education trust fund or anything just
with this bottom line
am I hearing you correctly that you
would recommend that we take some money
from the 4700 base adequacy and move it
into spread move it to the right hand
side or I thought you were talking about
special education the governor's budget
already has an additional rate Beyond
where we are but you know yes I I
absolutely believe we need to put more
money there as well but wouldn't putting
it into the special education also keep
it on the left side but Target a bit
better to the towns that because if if
there is one thing that's amazingly
expensive is a special education student
right I mean they tend to take a
disproportion a large amount of
resources because they have you know
specific specific needs that we need to
address
so is that what you're suggesting
because that's what I thought I heard
and I I probably wouldn't take special
education through other means too and we
haven't even addressed that special
education Aid catastrophic Aid there's a
formula which if you talk about broken
formulas there's the broken formula when
you have to put seventy thousand dollars
up first before you even start getting
state aid on this mandated program which
locals don't have any control over at
all and the way that schools are making
it right now
to a degree is a result of the 650
million dollars that came down through
the stabilization and the Esser monies
and and all the cares act all that and
they have Paris that they're paying now
however they're running out in 2024
that's basically going to go off the
cliff and you're we're going to see
where we're going to be really hit hard
so uh I I suggest that we try to look at
that top figure the governor has the
forty seven hundred dollars move part of
that and I think that's what we've
communicated in the past and also be
looking at education trust fund to help
do what we're talking about over here
something has to be done
um I agree with you but frankly that
just makes it I agree with you but I
think that makes it important to
preserve Those portions of the education
trust fund and funding because we
realize there will be
additional expenses we'll have to make
in the future to address the special
education
I I agreement a degree on that but you
look at what's going on today you can't
a dollar can't buy a loaf of bread
anymore and you leave it in that trust
and what's it going to be doing for you
there just sitting there as parmie
it loses money because of inflation that
that Joe that's where I am right exactly
thank you
okay I don't know that got us down the
road Mick do you know what we're gonna
I think it's so I think for me it's the
difference between the 4700 and I I'm
hearing 4 500
proposal four four yeah is that four or
five which one is anybody
I would say for
and then take the take that difference
and put it in on the right hand side
Mr chair if I had a vote today I'd go
with proposal nine so so if if I can go
to to five I would feel much more
comfortable I'm looking at the
difference between the governor's
recommended the numbers all the way down
the sheet and proposal five it gets me
closer to the goal that I'm
I'm working towards I think you know if
you look at Hanover my my district my
home District you know 1.9 million
increased because of Base Aid would go
down under proposal 5 to 1.29 million
it's still a lot of money to hand over
that we don't currently need and I know
that we could be targeting it better so
you know the difference between 1.5 and
1.2 is
not huge in my district and I I you know
if I can send that money to districts
that really could use the extra three
hundred thousand dollars a year in the
first biennium then that's that's
exactly what I should be voting for so
proposal five is if I am forced to
choose between the governor's proposal
four and five I'm choosing five I um I
would suggest that both four and five be
prepared please because I'm not sure if
I can go all the way to five
and when you say prepared plus 20
million a year yes so I can run that
analysis I can run the governor's
recommended with plus 20 million and
then I can run four and five if you'd
like plus 20 million and just to make it
clear that 20 million will all be
targeted
yes and then just one thing to think
about as we just to prepare for this
afternoon the governor's budget changes
the extraordinary needs Grant by
increases it by 50 every biennium it's
starting at 650 dollars
proposal four or five or even the
governor's plus 20 any of these plus 20
million the the extraordinary needs
Grant is going to be multiple thousand
dollars so you just want to what's your
policy not sure you're going to want to
increase that by 50 per year that's
going to get pretty pretty large in
those out years so that's something just
to think about
we might have to modify that provision
of hb2 if you do increase the
extraordinary needs Grant so just
nothing you have to decide right now but
something to think about if we're gonna
do a Ed funding plan Beyond two years so
you're saying that if the governor's
budget increasing 50 percent each year
that's it that's huge so in so under
current law
it's 650 per equalized valuation per
free and reduced lunch people for
Extraordinary needs 50 per year or
biennium in the governors goes out to
the fiscal uh 2034 by any of it only
gets up to I say only but it gets up to
just under five thousand dollars
but if what we're talking about here is
targeting an extra 20 million
extraordinary extraordinary needs you
may be doing four thousand dollars per
pupil this year so that plus 50 for each
of the next two by any is gonna
explained and I think that was the
intention
I think I would just just think about
that between now and this afternoon and
we can talk more about that later if I
may suggest could we ask Miki to
calculate the percentage increase which
over 10 years would result in a similar
final increases with the governors it's
just you know a new exponential that
would it would slow the great to get to
the similar point because I'm concerned
seriously about blowing up the state
budget in 10 years if the law would be
you know as is I I love doing that type
of analysis I really do we're down to
hours to when we can never mind I would
love to provide that but there would
have been weeks ago we would have had to
have started that I think
put this increase to this biennium so
that we're owning it only for this
biennium
I if I had to make a bet
um we this formula will never get out to
10 years
um just because of all the variables
that are occurring outside it so I think
we should just concentrate on this
biennium and and our actions can be um
in hp2 that says that
well that's that's all we're affecting
right right right that's the facts but
that that but
going out 10 years I don't think would
serve us well right now I think it isn't
it wasn't Mickey saying that the
governor's budget spends it out over
um 10 years or so so and I think you
know we can't predict the future you
don't want to legislate for the future
this is a significant I think a very
good change I think this is a positive
change so I think in two years seeing
where the schools are and where we are
then that becomes a new starting point
to see how we adjust that so I think
this is enough of a change that I don't
think it would be useful to try to spin
out what this would look like to try to
match it exactly to the governor's
proposal but to say instead of having
his do it over the 10 years let's get
this in for this two years and not start
trying to predict the future
agreed okay
moving on so in and I'll put that
together for after just one thing to
keep in mind
even though the intentions not to change
it every two years or the next 10 years
you do have to set a law of what it will
be in fiscal 26. so the law has to say
what the formula would be in 26 you
can't just say for these two years only
do this and no Ed funding in 26.
oh man if there's preliminary estimates
that the maybe Mark's going to talk
about that but they have to publish
preliminary estimates for fiscal 26
before you have a 25 legislative session
so they would need some sort whatever
you have on the books for law is what
they would publish as 26. yeah Mickey's
explaining it and Mark manganel Bureau
School finance department of education
um what Mickey's explaining is true
whatever you put into law is legally
binding so
um we take that number as a we don't say
we don't say that your intent that you
want to change it at some later date we
just say the law is the law so we would
make estimates that that acceleration
Factor would be what it is the one uh a
50 increase and then we would send
estimates and then school districts
would build their budgets off their
estimates and then at a later date you
made a a decrease in that because you
said we can't afford this they would be
building their budgets off a higher
Revenue so although you really you're
focusing on 24 25 and it's way too late
to do these complex uh product
projections out
um you do have to consider
um whatever you pass this law you do
have to treat it as if it is locked
because that is how the Department's in
so I think we're good with that for now
I'll do some work while a few folks are
busy across the hall this afternoon and
if we meet after that I'll have some
more more stuff for us
yeah
okay
so we can
we can agree that 125
will go to full Finance with no
recommendation
no the wetlands no
oh I'm just I just happened my eyes just
fell on that one so do you do you want
to start at the top Mr chair do you want
to jump to we can go wherever you want
to go let's start at the top sorry
if I could briefly before we go to the
new topics the analysis I was asking
Mickey for
um it will just take 30 seconds right
now we are starting from 6 50 and we are
going to 49 36 by 50 increases if we
would start for example at 1100 because
of all the money we are looking to move
to the right side in the same amount of
time instead of 49 36 will be going to
83.53
and in order to achieve the same 4936 in
the same amount of time instead of 50
percent we'd have to change hb2 to
increase by about 35 percent
I would just want to State for the
record and then we can go to our you
know plan discussion that I don't think
I would be comfortable increasing the
right hand side without also adjusting
the percentage of increase to make sure
that we don't end up with huge increases
that's that's all I just wanted to share
that really quickly and we can return
too
well so that we don't start from a much
higher base and then exponentially
increase because those increases will be
spectacularly expensive and we cannot
write law counting on the fact that
somebody is going to fix this huge
amount of promises we make that we could
have we could never write those checks
I'm not going to sign a check I cannot
write
okay
where we are is so you do have a new
tracking sheet package today with
amendments
um and I did update that and I'll point
us to a couple of changes that I made
um
later on in this document so I don't
know if we're ready to take a vote on
the section six and seven relative to
the retirement system uh retirement
system for ccs and H employees after
January 1 2024.
well
uh my it's just a matter of principle
that this would re uh have an impact on
the SEIU and all members for the
community caller system after 24 would
not be part of the retirement system
which could have an impact on the
overall Retirement System
yeah I can just Echo I don't want to
take I feel badly I don't want to take
Choice away from anyone but I because
there's a significant fiscal impact I do
not understand I don't know what that
impact would be on the retirement system
which is already struggling on its own
so I just am not comfortable with that
please
thank you
so
um Sally fellow state representative for
Grafton 8 which is Plymouth Ashland in
holdiness
um also a member of the retirement
system I would just say for the
Community College people I think that
that that's should be up to them to
decide whether or not if they want to if
they think it's a good idea to pull out
of the retirement system for the ones in
the future that they should make that
own decision and also to say that every
employee
um who whether they're in the any
employee anywhere always has the option
to do their own retirement planning with
the IRA or also
um if they work for the state you can do
onent
it's if you're if you're a government
employee has a different number so I
don't know exactly what it's called but
it's like an IRA it's a Deferred Comp so
you're not paying taxes on it when you
put it in you pay taxes when you take it
out so I think people
um people come from different places in
terms of what points in their life they
are in a good position to plan for
retirement and to put money in
retirement so one you know some people
want to save as much money as they can
um through their their whole time of
employment but sometimes people don't
want to put away money for retirement
until after they've had the opportunity
to for example to buy a house and
they're making high mortgage payments
there are also people who have a lot of
debt from college
but that gave them a percentage when
they're going to earn more money later
so when they are able to put money into
retirements
you know their own retirement savings
should be something that they plan out
on themselves because P different people
are in very different positions all
questions yeah well I I'd just like to
make comment I agree with representative
fellows and uh also this becomes their
money versus the retirement's money
and uh I agree with her 100 thank you
thank you
I I wonder if he misunderstood I
money
employees put into the retirement system
if they leave they can take it out
but
I just think for some people the
retirement system works so to pull them
out isn't necessarily a good idea
um for other people they just you know I
think everybody should have the
opportunity to be in the retirement
system and
um if they want to make extra
contributions on their own they can do
that
but there are two very different systems
the retirement system gives you a
defined benefit
the when when you put your money in
um
an IRA or you put it in mutual funds
which is where a lot of money goes
that's a contribution and you really
don't know what you're going to end up
with in the end and it depends at what
point the stock market takes a big dive
and when you're ready for retirement so
that is very risky I think they should
have the opportunity to do both fine
thank you representative fellows
Chancellor would you like to make a
comment
thank you good morning Mark Rubinstein
community college system of New
Hampshire good to see you let me just
start the preface in saying retirement
planning in this country is is broken
that's a serious problem the specific
request that we made was actually for
our board to have the authority to make
a determination of the future some
future date for newly hired employees
not currently eligible the language that
has come forward is that effect of a
certain date no new employees not
currently eligible would be in
and part part of our thinking about this
is that our board has a fiduciary
responsibility on behalf of the state an
effective 2007 when we became an
independent body politic and corporate
um property transfer to the
responsibility of the community college
system effective July 1 2011 but there
was never a date certain about
continuing as employees within the state
Employee Retirement System
we are going to continue to be
responsible for anyone who's currently
in who's currently eligible anyone who
might be hired at a future date who's
already in ineligible perhaps coming
from another state agency so this is
going to have a very limited and slow
effect on our finances but it was
important for our board and with that
fiduciary responsibility to articulate
that that need to have some measure of
control we currently do offer a 403 b
plan
as well as 457 plan through Fidelity and
the contribution of the employer is
eight percent and it's established by
our Board of Trustees the contribution
for employees in the state retirement
system so I have closer to 14 percent
and the determination is made by that
board
that's a almost a six percent difference
and we have no control over that so in
trying to manage long-term expenses this
is a area of responsibility the board
has and that's the basis for
articulating the request initially that
if the board is accountable for this the
board should have a voice in managing
that facet of our expenses long term but
we recognize I say for anyone currently
in anyone currently retired all of those
obligations are ours and will continue
to honor them it really was a
forward-looking uh stake in the ground
if you will to be again to bend that
curve
questions
um would the system have the ability to
continue making the necessary
contributions for the existing employees
without the new employees that come and
you know add their own contributions
because this is generally the concern
when you switch from a defined benefit
which is counting on New Years of people
coming in to sustain the benefits for
the people when you take the pipeline of
people coming in or cut it down you have
fewer funds you also have fewer future
obligations but there is a period when
you still have to find the existing
people are you concerned you know are
you comfortable handing handling that
impact
the size of our Workforce in terms of
participants eligible is probably about
650 people so relative to the scale of
the entire Workforce the number of new
hires in a year who are potentially
eligible potentially 30 or 40. I I don't
think that that's the math that this
group or I should be as worried about as
the breadth of the State Employee
Retirement System obviously which is a
scary number that I'm gonna not mention
again because it's been repeated 50
times and okay I appreciate it thank you
I'll I'll only add that currently
through negotiation our staff are able
to make a choice between the state
Employee Retirement System and the 403 b
our full-time faculty we've not been
able to negotiate agreement to make that
an option to choose the 403 b for some
people the portability the ability to
trust if you will the economy of the
country in the world you know is is in
some ways more comforting than when they
look at the long-term Horizon for the
retirement system and worry about that
so right now we don't have the absolute
flexibility our employees don't have the
can you just iterate the downside to the
retirement system of this I mean what's
the impact that this will have on the
retirement system as it is now I'm
beginning to hear that you don't think
it's going to be a significant change
well so looking at from the perspective
of the community college system
relatively small number of new hires
each year really won't change the
responsibility we have for those already
retired for those who are eligible and
can will continue to be eligible and
retire over the next 10 20 30 years
um but for the State Employee Retirement
System I think our numbers are so small
relative to the scale of other
participants in the state municipalities
that I don't think that we have a
significant detrimental effect and I
think we're sufficiently unique in
statute that I don't know that we become
the Leading Edge of other entities that
would would then choose to follow suit I
can appreciate that that would be a
concern but again I think we're
significantly sufficiently I should say
unique
okay thank you anyone else want to
look I'm going to put her on hold for a
huh
I don't know how we don't make a
recommendation don't go into full
Finance so if you recall I discussed
this when we first convened as far as
how this would work
um the way that I think all divisions
are treating a 4-4 vote is you're making
no changes to what's in house bill 2. so
you're not proposing an amendment you're
not proposing to delete so that section
would be essentially still in the
underlying House Bill too
essentially surviving as the governor
put it forward
is that are under that's fine with me
I'm fine with that too I think that it
just gives the opportunity to say that
there was a question that was concerned
about the impact on the retirement
system you know in principle I support
this but just with that you know the
fiscal mind that I have to feel I feel I
have to say that
um we don't under I don't understand how
this would affect the retirement system
I can believe that it's probably not a
lot because it's a huge system and
you're talking about a few people who
may not want to participate and there'll
be people who will so I think it's just
an opportunity to say there was a
question about how this would impact the
retirement system
while I cannot put numbers on that
because that would require a deeper dive
into Actuarial data I can I'm very
comfortable saying that any one employee
that could enter the retirement system
choosing instead a non-retirement system
option or being over that choice only
would result in a short-term downside
because their contributions would not be
there but a net savings over time
because at the end we wouldn't have the
obligations that we have that right now
we have underfunded so it would be a
short-term loss for a significant
long-term gain but again I'm not going
to put dollar numbers on it because that
requires
apologies in return just for a point of
clarification as it's currently written
in House Bill 2.
ccs and H community colleges will no
longer be an eligible employer after
this date so there would not be the
choice to be in or out
I didn't want to leave this group with
that confusion as I said earlier
currently our full-time faculty also
don't have a choice to be in or out our
staff have agreed to give one another
that option of being in or out but for
some folks the need to be here for 10
years to be vested is a barrier it makes
us a less attractive employer than
others because some folks have plans to
be more mobile than that
okay well I I had forgotten that point
that if we if if we deadlock it stays as
sections
eight and nine so yes the next two areas
of the UNH interoperability lab
appropriation in the Whittemore Center
appropriation we haven't officially
decided to keep those in modify them in
what's anybody feeling on this because
these are coming out of surplus of 23.
these are fiscal 23 general fund
Appropriations correct
I you know I'll go out there to say I
support both of them
um I wish I knew what division two's
appropriation or you know our
part of the pie of the general fund was
that would make it easier for us to do
prioritizing of these things because we
just don't have a clue of what what
money from General funds is going to be
allocated to division two but not
knowing that I support both these things
comment
motion oh could I just add a comment Mr
chair before we take a quick vote um my
understanding of reviewing the testimony
is that both of the Appropriations we're
talking about right now have the
opportunity to be a revenue generator
for the institution and I think uh you
know the small investment
I shouldn't say small I should say the
return on investment will be quite high
for for both of those opportunities and
so while I share Kate's concern about
prioritization I think generally it's a
it's a wonderful opportunity for unh
to answer your question about where are
we
it's just perhaps my memory is faulty
but it seems to me in past Cycles at
some point prior to this chair would pop
in and say division two your section of
your part of the general funds is this
amount try to put you know your
priorities and fitted within this amount
of money that we're allotting you
um one year division one came over and
said we have an extra 17 million would
like you to put an education so there's
been communication around
this instead of you know we can make
this is like doing the Christmas list uh
which is fine except it it's makes me
think in a different way if I already
have a limit of what that pot is
okay I would just say at this point
we're we're calculating or we're
including things that are in the
governor's budget for Appropriations as
already accounted for so if you wanted
to for instance fund anything on the
next page there
I would say at this point the committee
should probably just consider staying
within itself so let's I'm just going to
use round numbers there's a Civics
appropriation for a textbook 2 million
if you took that out and then funded
something for 2 million on the other
other end that I think we're okay to
live in that area right now the other
divisions are meeting as we speak
they're using they're throwing around
much bigger numbers than we are and I
think some of these smaller decisions I
think if whatever you want to do if you
stay within yourself you're okay uh
maybe we'll have a better idea at the
end of the day after the divisions do
work this morning but I
I don't think we're going to get a clear
um here's X dollars for division two
here's X dollars for division three
yeah
I I visited Whittemore Center I do agree
that they do need to get some of that
work done but given the amount of
pressure we have this is just not a high
priority for me so if you ask me to vote
right now I would probably vote no
because I just don't see where I would
fit it in the current we are over in
every category and we haven't even
really talked about the bills that were
positive require even more money some of
them and I I would like to be able to
find a way to fund it
but right now I I wouldn't be confident
that we can find that and I don't want
to put it in and then take it out
tomorrow
I I think the point is that does happen
all the time okay once once you figure
out what you got because we really don't
know what the Surplus is going to be
no Mary
one point
um the governor's office actually has
asked particularly for the 1.5 for the
interoperability lab appropriation
because of the significance that it will
play in in the future in terms of of the
business relations that are going to
come out of that and that they will also
want to use the Whittemore Center I
completely agree that um it is an
Enterprise facility
and you know what we have undercut the
university system for years and years
and years if we couldn't do 8 million
maybe four million
um just cut the Appropriations in half
and and that would at least get them
halfway there they're going to get funds
from other resources that's what UNH has
learned how to do so I wouldn't be um
opposed if we
um did 50 of each at this point in time
and that would give us a few extra
dollars uh with which to work in other
areas because I think there are quite a
frankly I would prefer to fully fund the
interoperability lab
and you know cut a little bit more from
the Whittemore Center which I'm willing
to cut to zero right now
but I think the weaker mode the
interoperability lab is to me a higher
priority because it has much more of a
strategic importance in terms of
education and developing business
opportunities and all that
the whittlemore center again I wish I I
will continue working to find a way to
get it done but I right now I don't see
I would suggest
um since this University money
um I have you know two possibilities one
um that we cut the Whittemore center of
the 1.5 million to fully fund the inter
interoperability but that leaves the 6.5
um towards the Whittemore Center which I
prefer to the 50 but the other thing I'd
consider and um
Nikki reminded me the I can't I'm the
Civics appropriation is the two million
dollars they can do that on their own
and to put that 2 million back up which
would get us back to fully funding the
whittlemore center and on inoperability
but I think the Civics money is money
that can be found privately and it's a
other opinions no opinion I just uh no I
think uh interoperability I'll move that
I think we have the support for that uh
let's move and get it out of the way so
this leaving it at 1.5 million exactly
second all those in favor
okay one down
swinging hard
uh 64 and 65 section
Department of Education computer science
Appropriations
uh
and then the next one was the commission
of New Hampshire Civics appropriation
that's a
7 million approximately
and if you throw in teacher of the year
it is seven million
yes so I think if we even go up to 62
um that was not a request from the doe
62 63 64 through 65.
um I think that was amended
64 and 65 Mickey yeah so we we adopted
an amendment earlier in the process here
to split some of the money out of one of
the Appropriations to fund the position
if you recall that newly established
position had no funding Associated to it
so there's an amendment later on if the
intent here is to revisit all this we
would supersede that Amendment with
whatever we're looking to do I'm good
so we left enough in to fund the
position
as part of that 4.955 million dollars is
that in
but eliminate 62 and 63 because they're
going to be starting their work and
we've put in a position so really they
need a little time to get off the ground
so I think we could live with us the 62
and 63 lines
but we again there was no change on that
week we accepted it previously I
understand
we did and and the Appropriations in
section 64 tied to
that program and the administrator
position so okay uh you may want to we
may just want to actually go through the
language I'm not sure if you want to set
up a program without any money they
might not I don't know that's up to it's
up to you but the money for that program
is the 4.955 that's and those are the
positions and the position is funded by
that too
all right then you skip down to uh
86 sections 86 through 88 which is the
commission of New Hampshire Civics
appropriation
we amended that by doing what I don't I
don't remember
we we made it so at least one of the
public members appointed by the governor
was a parent of a child in a New
Hampshire education program that was the
and that amendment is in your packets
here too
yes page 12.
I'm fine with the commission but I would
pull out the money for the book
okay that's easily raised by private
funds
Mr chair yes if I may um there is a very
active Civics group in the state
um and
I I don't know why we actually need this
again it's
where the
general court is not in the practice of
normally dictating curriculum and and I
don't know if that's the intent of this
book that's going to come out
but I think we could live without that 2
million appropriation
if we if we zero that out
is that two million can be used on the
second page
yeah I mean essentially I'd say in the
in those dollars that we're talking
about just a couple million whether it's
23 24 25 you can assume you can use that
in the other years yes
if I may make a suggestion would it be
more productive to go to the second page
and see what we want to add and that
would help us figure out what we may
want to cut
well it's just I'm I'm finding either
way but it would look to me like I would
want to know what I want to add before I
I mean right now it's in the budget we
can cut it anytime
if we need to
I'm comfortable just going through this
because I think I can use a refresher
and we've added more information we've
learned something so there may be things
we need to revisit
well
I I'm going along with the idea that
getting in the book writing business is
probably not the best legislative action
we can take
so
I would make that motion that we just we
removed that line okay from hb2 and
funding associated with it
about the commission
there's already an active
um
they're very active group led by I think
but you know I'm fine with the
commission um if we you know I think
it's fine to say we think this is
important but I agree with the chair
that we don't need to do the book but to
support the concept I'm totally fine
with that could somebody remind me if
that 2 million was all for the book
development or part of it was for the
commission operations I would appreciate
the refresher on that
it just says for the purposes of
creating a New Hampshire Civics textbook
to be distributed to every New Hampshire
Civics classroom that's the purpose of
hi
so yes
or
we're glad April years ago when I was a
principal over in Maine and I was also
working with the Maine legislature and
their state cultural activities there
I wrote a curriculum for that state in
conjunction with a state Grant and
federal monies which are available which
is the main studies curriculum project
since that date the poll Project's been
bought out by DownEast magazine
the copyright the whole nine yards I
didn't get anything out of it but I
think that's appropriate that if we get
into this curriculum writing business
there's a way to do this already
established through your grant writing
and receiving those types of dollars but
in conjunction of working with or other
organizations as well I I you know in
terms of where we are in education right
here this is not on the top of our
priority list
thank you okay
let's put a tick mark by that one to say
if we need it on the subsequent pages
that one disappears
all right
along with the
kittens but at the teacher of the year
and no changes to the computer science
appropriation at this point either
keeping that as we've previously
okay
yeah I think so
and if we go down then to the Department
of Transportation
that one would go forward but because
we're a hung jury on that one
no there's no money in it it's just it's
just
it's just what it says I'm sorry yeah
now can we uh I hate to do it uh we've
gotten pushed back on the northern
border Alliance program
they don't want it up there
um I'm happy you know I I'm uh happy to
support safety and all that but
um there's been pushback about whether
or not there's need and there just don't
seem to
so you know it may be something we can
reconsider
um I was supportive of it I
can see that maybe it's not a necessary
thing and I can certainly hear that some
people are bothered by it but anyway
just for put it on the floor okay
um I would just like to concur with
representative Murray I too have gotten
a lot of um emails uh asking that we
revisit that vote that we took and if
possible delete that from the section as
well thank you
so we got four potentially on The
any any other items on this page of what
anybody wants to reconsider
a lot of them we did we went no change
so
oh that was moving a position from
HHS to the fire marshal okay yeah yeah
so if you remember uh Department of
Safety had mentioned that there was a
couple of sections in-house Bill 2
related to this and this one they
recommended to be deleted there's
another section that's assigned to
division three that they said does what
they need to do okay yep yep yep
suspension of RSA relative to
appropriations of Highway funds and
that's the compliance section that we
talked about so when the when you're
done making your decisions with the
highway fund all determine if we need to
keep that in there or not okay and I
don't think we will need to keep it in
education trust fund and distribution
same thing uh that one's a little
different this essentially uh goes to
the
proposal that representative Weiler was
discussing as far as shifting a lot of
programs from the education trust fund
to the general fund right so this this
amendment if you know or an amendment to
this section would be in love to if
represent Weiler is going to propose
that okay
so that's why that's open at this point
all right
everything from 171 through 177
I'll take care of depending on what we
do with Ed funding with adequacy
and then 210 to 11 may also get rolled
into representative Weiler's uh proposal
relative to education trust fund uses
and the revenue that goes into the
education trust fund okay
we do have
representative Hall's amendment is still
pending as long as along with the issue
of school building Aid which we haven't
really settled on that yet we have a
couple of bills that are retained in the
committee
we're probably not in a place to dive
into that now unless unless you are I
don't know I think I think we heard some
uh we had some comments on
representative hole's Amendment and I
think that's going to be in drafting to
clean up a couple of those concerns and
represent it to division two for
consideration okay
when
so those comments came to me uh
yesterday and this morning I'm just
asking how much more time do we have I
think tomorrow is the hard deadline to
make any decisions or I'm just trying
yeah that's it okay so okay we'll soon
see
today and tomorrow the party ends
to
be of Sugar Hill Technical Center we
need to make a decision on that role at
gym right all right I had that as we had
decided to keep those sections in yeah
but keep it in okay and I will say this
may be impacted by
representative weilers and his what he
wants to do with ETF and general funds
so the amount would still be funded but
this may be one of the programs that
shifts to the general fund
yes a question about this
um
no we know that we have a number of
items that we've decided to pay
or to fill using the education trust if
we're representative Weiler's amendments
should succeed
what happens does that mean we have to
shift all those dollars that we had
intended for the education trust into
the general fund correct
correct
thank you
isn't it
inquiring him about this
the answer I got was the original
adequacy formula they had to set up the
trust fund to satisfy the court
right and but it's grown because of the
contributions
and so now it's become the education
slush fund
so the idea was to get back to what it
was originally attended so because of
what's Happening money goes into this
yes so if I may
this presents a real challenge because
all of a sudden we're moving millions of
dollars into the general fund which
apparently we're going to be very
stretched for
could we do this if in fact
representative Weiler's motion passes
and succeeds could we as a one time for
this biennium use the trust for the
purposes originally intended
only in this biennium and then if
everybody votes to agree to limit what
goes into the education trust in the
next biennium but maintain it for this
biennium
all depends on his motion
I can solicit that
and that's essentially just changing the
effective date of his amendment to one
July 25 is we'll get to the essence of
that I I don't see that as making any
real difference at this point in time
just my personal opinion because at the
end of the day it's this community that
will decide both on the funding and
doing the expenditures and whether we
take it from one pocket to the other you
know it's still the same amount of money
we are planning to spend
uh if I may it does significantly impact
our work because every time we take
something out of the education trust
fund
it goes into the general fund so that
means there's something in the general
fund that isn't going to get funded
because we've moved a significant amount
of money so if we were to
excuse me if I just let me finish please
we the general fund is its own pot of
money
education trust has uses that have been
defined
for this biennium so if we could retain
them in this biennium
and then the changes would be impacted
with the new date
as a effective 25
Mickey
um then it would not it
it would make us it would make it really
difficult for us let's say for example
if we wanted to put enough money in
building aid for those two other
projects that we'd like to see get
funded we wouldn't be able to use that
building we wouldn't be able to use
education trust money for that purpose
because it's in the trust if it's in the
general fund we can't take education
trust money and put it into the general
fund we can take general fund money and
put it in the trust but not the other
way around that's why it would really
we'd be in a conundrum of what we can
fund and what we can't fund it's much
easier if we keep education trust as is
for now and then in the future whatever
they decide then we can account for that
in the preparation of the budget process
if I may
first I want to say that I had no
intention of interrupting I merely raise
my hand to say let the chairman know
that I would like to follow up I
obviously you know want to make sure
that everybody gets to finish what they
want to say every time thank you of
course and I I just wanna I I hear what
you are saying but in this case to me it
looks like we are moving both the
revenues and the expenditures from one
pocket to the other it doesn't change
the total amount of Revenue or the total
amount of expenditures it just changes
whether they come from a restricted
order unrestricted pocket
or this biennium so that's what I was
trying to say that you know it doesn't
really change the bottom line in any way
but I do completely acknowledge that it
changes the nature of the pocket we are
planning to spend from and that may have
impact on future
um legislatures thank you
okay
what what item did you ask about oh
Sugar Hill yes yes all right a lot
coming out of here yes and it would come
out of the trust I believe yeah and the
other the other CTE is coming out of uh
capital budget yes and they're talking
when a Squam is currently in the capital
budget yeah this yeah this came out of
this is coming out of here because there
is extra money in the education trust
funds and that's why the governor put it
even though it's a capital all right
we can all argue all right go to page
three
so just a refresher these are mostly
requests that the agencies brought
forward to you most of them are
additional prioritized needs that were
also in their agency budget requests
brought to the governor that were not
included in the governor's recommended
budget so about 85 to 90 percent of
these are are things that have been
requests for a little bit of time now
through this process I will point you
briefly to one on line 18.
so if you remember the department of
safety had talked about the costs of
their credit card acceptance that DMV
was getting a little out of control so
rather than
um
Levy a convenience fee or a surcharge to
the users or to the consumers customers
they had asked for some additional
appropriation to cover those those fees
I can tell you they do have an item that
they're bringing to the fiscal committee
this Friday to draw from the highway
fund to cover those costs for this year
assuming that's approved by fiscal
this request would essentially carry on
that that funding policy if you will for
the next for the next two years
you would have to act on this so this
would this would give them the money for
24 and 25 the money they're coming for
for fiscal would only be for this year
oh oh what can you know just just a
moment
um every other entity it seems in the
world charges something for their credit
card fees and I'm a little baffled as to
why the DMV doesn't add that cost to the
cost of you know that when we go you pay
the credit card fee when you go out for
dinner when you buy clothes you're
paying the credit card fee if you use
your credit card and why DMV doesn't add
that on it seems to me this is an
internal issue where they could cover
this themselves if they charge for the
fee
I've I've dealt with that in the town of
Windham so I can shed some light into
that Merchants can set their prices to
anything they want and yes if they want
to keep a hundred dollars they charge
you 102 knowing that two dollars will go
to the credit card company our fees are
set by Statute so we don't have the
option to add that right without
increasing and disclosing it separately
in the town of Windham we did do exactly
that we basically
allowed our town clerk and our tax
collector to charge an additional fee of
two point something percent on top of
the transaction so that is an option but
as long as it's clearly disclosed they
could do that I think they are looking
to do this because they would rather not
you know increase the costs on the
people who are using credit cards so
frankly are probably the ones who
can list the 40 additional fees I mean
people who use credit cards
because they cannot write a check you
know they are the ones who have a hard
time you know paying for anything
if I may
if I may clarify so that we eliminate
this apparent confusion
there are two major reasons for using a
credit card people like me who pay in
full every month and love to get their
1.5 or 2 percent cash back absolutely
that is me I specifically said the
people who use credit cards because they
cannot pay through you know direct means
the people who carry a balance
those are two different categories of
people I never implied that all of them
belong to one pocket I was talking about
the specific Pockets who would do this
out of need rather of you know Financial
so it's an Appropriations so and I will
jump let's jump to page seven real quick
I'll show you what's going on with the
highway fund it's going to look a little
different than our last uh our last
handout
so also in addition to the Department of
Safety request for additional Highway
funds for fiscal 23 there's also a DOT
winter maintenance item for just over
six million dollars I've accounted those
under the presumption they will clear
fiscal and Governor Council which brings
your balance I think it was 12.9 Million
last time we met just over 6.3 million
now in the highway fund so as you make
Highway fund decisions that's our
balance that we're working from at this
point
uh it's been we've had multiple budgets
here in the last few years where uh
General funds can be transferred into
the highway fund so when you see let's
say hypothetically you wanted to reduce
the Civics textbook and give Department
of Transportation two million dollars I
can make that happen so don't worry that
a request says Highway funds but you're
cutting General funds and you know I can
I can do the technical component to do a
fund transfer in House Bill too to make
that work does that sound like a
reasonable trade-off
and and maybe that's fine for me and I
think maybe what we do is just
tentatively think about these things and
maybe we'll
put put a sheet together that kind of
makes it clear if you're making
reductions in ads okay you know I'll
document that I don't want too many
things flying around that it's unclear
the work we're doing so so are we going
and improving this then
so so the two million dollar for which
one now this would be the Division of
Motor Vehicles yeah
you're saying the Safety Division and
the highway fund okay
we're moving the two million dollars
into the highway fund and that was a
hypothetical two million dollars so uh
so I mean you could you could and it
would Shore up the highway funds but
isn't it that was just my example of I
can turn General funds into Highway
funds you know just with a fund transfer
for looking at Line 6 18 is that is that
the line you're having us
on page three it's just I'm having you
consider this I just wanted to give you
that information about that they're
bringing this forward to fiscal
committee this week for fiscal 23. so uh
under the presumption that it passes
fiscal they'd have funds to pay for in
23. this request here is that they'd
so they're going to go to fish gallon
Hawaii so we might as well prove it and
get it out of the way
well if we're saying there's a fly on
the baby's head get a hammer
I mean they're asking for two hundred
thousand you you reference two million
dollars
well I know the two million was just uh
that is because that's how much the
Civics textbook was so that's why all
right that was just a hypothetical
so
you you could um you could accept 18 if
that's what you wanted to do and I'll
still keep everyone updated on that
status of the highway fund and if you
need to move General funds in there at
show of hands
okay Mr chair
um the people from the community college
are here and I think they have some
information that they want to share with
us about some of the items that we have
to make decisions on okay so that might
be something I think we can easily work
through
please
thank you
Mark Rubinstein community college system
good to see you all again a couple of
things on the list uh item uh 50
Workforce credentials
this is primarily for working adults and
currently the federal government is
looking at a couple of different bills
that might or might not survive
legislative process federal financial
aid doesn't support this this is a
critical opportunity and something that
we can tailor whether it's hospitality
or health care to different needs around
the state
even the opportunity to Pilot this
because currently there's not support as
I said in in federal programs for this
if we could reduce that to a million
dollars that would give us the
opportunity to probably work with
between five and six hundred adults
across the state to work on credentials
again tailored to different areas of the
state different Industries to move
people up in the workforce
my preference would be to take the two
million dollar Civics book and put a
I'm fine with that basically I I would
like to support this type of program as
much as possible because having been
involved in that type of training I know
what the difference it can make for
people who want to change a career or
acquire a skill or just move in a
different direction it's the kind of
flexibility in the workforce that we
desperately need at all times people
shift careers all the time we should
support that
okay show hands everybody on that reason
I'm supporting it but could we hear the
entire story I don't know that's just
one item yeah so I would like to hear
you know the whole the Gestalt
okay and the other one I'd like to speak
to is in row 52 which is identified as
tuition reset and promise program when
we put this proposal together originally
uh early in the budget cycle we were
working with some rough estimates I'd
like to refine that to three million
dollars from the eight that's there
three million in each year this would
serve between 1200 and 1500 students
primarily more traditional age students
18 to 25. this is an opportunity to
remove cost as a barrier for students
who are prepared to move through in
relatively uh good order this ties to
what we're trying to do with House Bill
420 the Dual and concurrent enrollment
it ties to what was accomplished last
year with how to house bill 1530
building Pathways between the community
college system and University system
again serving primarily more traditional
age students but the opportunity to
remove cost and facilitate timely
completion to degrees at both two-year
combination of changes to the federal
Pell Grant and also
looking at other sources of support for
this we think that we can accomplish
this at three million dollars a year
rather than the eight we originally
proposed
now this can come out of uh education
Trust
no
either way
I'm trying to spend that money down I
know but I think I'm going to change the
formula there will be less in the
education it's finding from the general
let's let's not worry about the funding
for oh I'm sorry go ahead
I just wanted to see
will find the money either pocket if we
decide to find the money okay the the
pocket will be figured out reasonably
straightforwardly I do think that this
is a very important program again those
are people who do need help and you know
I think we should continue to maintain
the tuition rates uh as flat as possible
because people are having a harder time
making ends meet and they need the
support
I have a question yes sir do you have
any employees that are working in a
program called diversity equity and
inclusion
um I don't believe we have anyone for
whom that is a role or a title doesn't
mean that we don't value inclusion
doesn't mean that we don't care about
the full spectrum of people that we
serve as students and whose work
benefits the state
it's become a very negative program I
don't like to see it anywhere and I see
it in your marketing
I don't like to it's it's just become a
very negative
thing that that many of us are averse to
so I hope you'll stop using it in your
marketing well I'm not entirely sure the
connotation my my point remains that we
have responsibility to every resident
the state of New Hampshire and our
efforts are to ensure that we're serving
all of them and so I don't know where
the how I would Implement what you've
just described well we've always done
that but I mean why is it important to
list the ethnicity of people in each of
I'm not I'm not sure where that's listed
we collect data for the federal
oh then based on the federal data we
collect based on the federal data that
it's racist to me that everybody has to
be identified by a race
um
I'll take your point but as I said we
collect the data because the federal
government asked us to collect the data
we share the information so that people
understand the scope of our work
well I'm just a verse I see the whole
program as being averse to what we
believe is we're all equal
okay do you have any other items you'd
like to highlight no those are the two
thank you okay
yes did I hear you correctly
um Chancellor that you said
um your original ask was for 8 million a
year but you understand you can run the
program through the 3 million that
you've subsequently asked for part of
this is sharper pencils part of this is
uh changes to the federal Pell grant
part of this is identifying other
sources that we can draw funds from
including unique in the governor's
and so you're you're more or less
withdrawing the solar and the critical
maintenance yes and critical maintenance
uh believe maybe interest through Public
Works and the solar will will
hold on that and one thing we've done I
think in the past and correct me if not
it's only the the you're only focusing
on these two products now or programs
now
um with reduced amounts what we've done
in some instances is to say we can find
this amount of money to give to you for
these programs you divide them up how
best you think it would work for your
situation
so it's just another option which gives
them a little more flexibility
I'd like to make a motion to uh allocate
to reduce that well but you've got to
we've got to figure out where's it
coming from
now it's got to come from somewhere all
right then give me a moment
oh I know what I have come on I've
already told you about waitamor for now
so I'd like to make a motion to
allocate the six million dollars and uh
that are needed for the tuition reset
over the biennium
and cut with a more completely for now
which would leave us with two more
million because I'm sure we'll have
other things that we'll want to put in
that's basically two motions I'm fine
with two separate motions and I would
respectfully wait until we have uh a
overview list to be able to see because
you know if we're going this way it's
kind of you know whack-a-mole that we
decide this oh but then there's this we
have to deal with this I'd rather see um
a larger spreadsheet about where we are
now things that we've decided we're not
going to do on one side and things that
we still like on the other side I think
it helps to see the overall picture
instead of um you know to me this is
playing whack-a-mole
other items on page three
that's Mary well based on the testimony
we're cutting we're
um
getting rid of item 54 53
then we're moving the Reset program for
3 million in each year the biennium for
6 million
and then we're looking at the credential
program at 1 million in each year with
the biennium so that would be two
million that one was voted on already
um so um
I would
accept that as a motion please
um that we um
as follows I think they've said that we
figure out everything we think we want
to fund
and then figure out all right so just
that we want to fund this yes yes and we
can eliminate the other lines as
indicated by the Community College yeah
that would be or not 54 and 53. no
further consideration this year this
doesn't exist anywhere except on this
so do we need a motion or are we just
going to hold on hold on is good so I
think we had consensus on Civics
textbook 2 million out expanding
Workforce credential in one million a
year I'll make that change and I'll
update the sheets accordingly I'll
remove the solar product projects in the
critical maintenance and I.T and update
the amounts in the promise program lines
thank you
the credit card fees still pending
credit card fees yes well I I think I
think we're good with that I think
everyone's okay with the credit card
fees adding that money there uh
I thought we raised all our hands on
this yeah I think we did that one number
18.
so flipping over to page four I think
the one that you maybe also want to
consider up or down at this point just
got to decide is the math learning
makes a 200 000 appropriation to the
community college system for that
program
if I may if you remember this is a
program that we used to have previously
I don't know if Shannon wants to talk at
all about the um
is that okay
Shannon Reed with the community college
system thank you the math learning
communities program is a partnership
between the community colleges and high
schools that opt in and it is aimed at
increasing the math preparedness the
college level math preparedness of high
school students which is perennially an
issue particularly with students who
want to go into any type of technical
field they need they need math
competency so we work with the high
schools to develop a curriculum that is
delivered in the high school the first
it essentially creates two courses the
first is a kind of a high school
excuse me high school level
um Math course which focuses on
competency students will need for the
next course which is a the Gateway Math
course for for college credit so
students can finish those two courses
and we know that they have the
competencies
um to succeed and and to have passed
that first level of college math
but I just wanted to speak to you know
support this because
you know my kid who's currently working
for a biotech in Boston did you know
very well in math in the high school and
yet her first year in uh translator was
a bit of an adjustment to those smart
courses so anything that helps bridge
that Gap because you know I know that
Windham works really hard and she was
doing really well there but anything
that would raise that level for the kids
who Wanna Go a bit further would help
them transition more successfully into
the college system and again those are
the kind of places where
I think a few dollars can make a very
big difference so to me those are the
kind of Investments we should favor over
other types of projects
thank you representative
I had a note from a parent that a
daughter wanted to was getting all A's
in school and and went to Boston
University wanting to go into pre-med
and she couldn't because she was taking
remedial math and English and so why do
we need all this remedial math we hear
so much about in all the colleges
because
the high schools aren't teaching math
right so this is a Cooperative effort to
try to reduce that the lady ended up not
even getting into pre-med because she'd
almost lost a semester with the remedial
stuff she had to do had to go to another
another major so it is important that if
they come out of high school especially
honors and and on and scholar and you
know the top list and then they can't do
yes
can I speak I was to sponsor that bill
okay
and we've been working over the years
with Beth Dorian over at the community
college system in HTI and we had 38 high
schools that have participated in this
program in the past and this program for
two hundred thousand dollars we're
getting the materials not the textbooks
aren't textbooks but we're getting the
teaching materials provided by the
community college system we're getting
uh those that are helping us from the
community college system we have
workshops established during the summer
months down at nhti this provides some
travel for the teachers come down we're
having teachers teaching teachers and
for those 38 schools and this is also
chapter law already in statute this is
there we just have not funded it seeing
that the grant that the community
college system received ran out and now
it's incumbent in us to try to continue
that but the students that are now
coming out after math foundations in the
11th grade and quantitative math in the
12th grade have proven to need less
remediation because now we are providing
instruction after we give the accuplacer
test
the Next Generation accuplacer test at
the end of the 10th grade we determine
by working with counselors by the parent
with the parent Administration in the
school and the Community College if this
youngster needs to go another track
because they really don't have those
foundational skills we get that and we
see that kids are coming out of this
program much better prepared and we're
no longer seeing for those that are
involved in this that 60 percent rate of
students that go on to Community College
that represent Weiler just mentioned
that need some kind we don't call it
Remediation in the community college
system anymore they're they're working
within the class uh trying to help them
out but we no longer have that 50
percent of that 60 percent that never
get a degree because they spend all this
money and time but they still couldn't
hack it we need to have this program at
the secondary level it's proven
effective and
um
we're getting more than a bang for the
buck and the community college system is
really helping us carry that burden okay
Mr chairman so moved Okay so
I think we're all in favor of this item
all right we'll find it somewhere
foreign
building age so we can fund all the rest
no
Mr chair we haven't crossed that bridge
yet
yes while I'm not saying that the amount
is appropriate is there any interest in
talking about HB 540 on the adequacy
grant special education amount increase
I think that's what we're going to
consider Mickey's going to do some more
okay so that's part of what we're you
know Meek is working on it's in regards
to that pill or item or what not I don't
I don't think we've decided we're doing
anything with special education and
since 540 that's why I'm asking I mean I
my takeaway is 529 and 540 will just
stay retained and that doesn't sound
like either of those bills components
will be incorporated into your final
proposal thread funding that's that's
that's my where I'm at right now if I
may ask a question yeah so
those bills that are retained
once the deadline budget for the budget
buses and we adopt the budget and it's
done
are we what is our window to do anything
with them I'm just I've never been
through this cycle so we kind of convene
as a committee in the fall okay and look
at all the retained bills and decide
does this need to have legislation for
next year okay so then we can draft
legislation that's be introduced in the
following year because I would like to
make sure that at least you know 529 and
even 540 I think they are very much
useful we may not have the time and the
resources right now but I just want to
see them continue to progress you know
that's that's up to us understood thank
you so there is still time to work on
them yes thank you
very
with the risk of probably jumping off a
cliff here
um do we want to talk about building air
we I know the hour is getting late but
um in the um Department of Ed's
um summary they have
43.1 and 43.4 uh for 24 and 25 listed in
their budget I was hoping that we could
use add to that line so that we could
fund at least conquered and Litchfield
so there'd be additional project I don't
know exactly how much that would be more
but I would put that out there for
I think the
School building Aid is one of our
biggest items that is still open right
now in the representative whole proposal
would completely change the school
building aid program effectively
repealing it so representative Heath's
discussion topic here is directly
related to what direction you go with
that Amendment so once that amendment's
cleaned up and brought back to this
committee Maybe by this afternoon that's
that's something you'll have to debate
and decide but we can well probably not
prepare to do that right now but
but the governor's budget had
has building Aid in it the governor's
budget includes the tail and and Debt
Service payments as well as about 48
million dollars for new school building
Aid projects this biennium and then if
you recall he set aside 75 million
dollars for school building aiding
future items this committee has already
decided not to do the 75 million we've
already reduced that but the remaining
uh 48 million for new projects this by
any name is still I think that covers
what you were trying what you were
saying uh it does not cover Litchfield
and Concord one no but if they're given
that much money that's really up to the
Department of Education and those
communities to figure out uh well we
heard from the Department it's a rank
list right so right all I'm saying is
they they've been playing with
approximately 25 million dollars now
they have 43 million dollars so 40 48
for the biennium for new projects oh for
the buy any yeah so that still
approximately 25 million yep and I think
that funds the first three for the for
these two years it's estimated that
would fund the first three projects and
the four and five are conquered
Litchfield those are not covered by the
governor's budget okay
but again
that in representative Hull's Amendment
and this completely conflicts so you
wouldn't do both you'd have to decide
which direction you're going to go just
a very quick note at least this year the
number two project warrant article
failed
whoever was number two
one and three are good to go but two did
not make it this year
out of the priority list the vote is
ready to go no I know I'm sure Concord
is ready to go that's number four right
I was talking about the number the top
three that Mickey was referring
there's also the CTE which the normally
goes in the public works but they've
they've filled up they could take care
of one CTE but not both we've got the
other one funded in Surplus and we
covered the other one yes I said under
building eight
no it's it's under Surplus for 23.
just like to take an opportunity Rick
lad he wrote again to talk to number two
which uh I don't want you to operate on
misinformation
um yes that they that concern is up and
Colebrook however
the superintendent Taylor did come down
when we're discussing the past Friday
School building Aid and the house
education committee since has modified
legislation when we're funding uh and
let's say the district's allocated
in-state support three million dollars
and and protect and I'll just say that
number just for Colebrook for example
and the folks up in Coburg have now gone
to other ways of attaining that money
and either be through a charitable trust
a gift or insurance
right now if we use monies like that to
in a project we offset the money which
is received by them may we take that you
know let's say two million dollars out
and they receive one million dollars for
the project
what they've been able to do they've
gone to benefactors up there and they
have received in donations and Gifts in
excess of two million dollars now so
that they want to be able to apply that
to you know the to the project and not
lose it uh um as a result of uh it the
way the legislation is presently written
we've modified that to take out yes if
you receive a Federal Grant or a state
grant that will come out of what we
um additional Grant additional federal
dollars that will come out of your state
school building Aid amount however if
you now receive a charitable trust or a
gift of some kind that will not and so
that's what they've done and the
community is really working hard to find
the money through that other alternative
fashion and then and they're just about
there
what about fish and game what not
the additional support for fish and game
so there's three general fund items
relative to fish and game on page three
you'll see those uh starting on line 29.
and then I also have the fish and game
fun Surplus statement on page eight of
your packet as it stands right now at
the end of the biennium the fish and
game fund has on a gap adjusted basis
four and a half million dollars of a
surplus so they're not going into the
red you'll you will see that that fund
balance does decline each year because
they are running a deficit essentially
from revenues and spending
they've brought forward three requests
for General funds
one is switching the funding for or I'll
start at the first one online 29. one
was to add a
two positions for six months at the end
of the biennium in general funds in 18
months of arpa money so that for that
grants available but only for the first
three quarters of the biennium and
there'd be 193 dollars 193 000 of
General funds for fiscal 25. the next
request was Colonel Jordan had talked
about just switching the funding source
for two correctional officers from Fish
and Game funds to General funds this
would be a general fund increase and
take a little bit of pressure off the
fish and game fund and then lastly these
numbers here on the general fund
transfer to The Fish and Game fund tie
to the amount of the pay raise the 10
and 2 percent appropriation that is
included in House Bill 2 the negotiated
pay raise increase the fish and game
fund is the fishing and department is
essentially asking for the general fund
to cover those costs for two years which
I can't recall that happening before and
and uh other funded agency situation
that the general fund would pay for
their any portion of their personnel
costs
commissioner told me the governor
promised that that's where this money
would come from because he said that 10
pay raise he didn't have in his budget
the governor said we'll put it in
general funds is it already in the
budget
so the fish and game Surplus that has a
four and a half million dollar ending
balance assumes it is paying for this
pay raise with Fish and Game funds
already which it's not this is the only
time we'll see the general fund cover of
that
it's just a request at this point the
governor did not put General funds in
there for the pay raise if they had
discussions about doing so it never
actually came in the budget that was
presented to this committee but they're
fun
if you look on page eight
line 11.
it is accounted for in the fish and game
fund okay so the four and a half million
dollar balance you see at the end
already covers the 10 and 2.
just to make a quick point though we are
spending down the balance of this fund
and since we are spending it at a faster
rate than we put any money into it by
now you can safely assume that anything
we found from that fund will sooner or
later become a general fund expense at
this rate
because you know I'm just saying that at
this point the distinction is temporary
all depends how many fishing licenses
they sell well the fish and game is
we've always put money in fishing game I
mean that covet change that a little bit
yeah because they're doing search and
rescue now too and that's more that's
not even uh it's not even close I can't
okay
we have to find the money to give them
the money
yeah just a minute that can go on our
we'd like to do this list but we don't
know if we've got the money to do it
so the hike safe isn't covered uh search
and rescue the hike safe is covering
search and rescue so the search and
rescue fund is is fine
this is the fish and game fund
this is just an effort to switch more of
their cos onto the general fund versus
The Fish and Game fund
with the under the uh
argument that they do work that's not
always directly related to the hunting
and fishing licenses that pay for the
fish and game funds so General fundsport
there is already two and a half million
dollars in this budget of General funds
in there covering correction officers
Colonel Jordan's request was to expand
foreign we'll have to see if Finance has
with that let's break for lunch and
we'll see you at one o'clock and we'll
recess Mr chair division two recess and
then after full committee you can decide
if you want to come back in here and
I'll have stuff for us so we'll recess
but no we've got to go to the big big
room for one yeah
we'll come back here after that if
all depends on how fast that goes yeah
it could take one hour it could take
okay we'll come out of recess
and we have a new handout for Mickey
so if you like to
walk us through it that would be great
uh sure so we're up to the scenarios
number 10 11 and 12. so these are the
three that we discussed this morning
so the first being essentially the
governor's recommended budget with an
additional approximate 20 million
dollars per year added to the
extraordinary needs Grant so you can see
that would put the extraordinary needs
Grant up to 37.50 is that on the cover
page here right proposal 11 is bringing
the base Aid down to 4500 the frame
reduced down to 23.80 using that money
would increase the maximum grant for
Extraordinary needs to 67.50 and then
proposal 12
4423 20 for base and free and reduce
respectively would give you enough to
fund eight thousand dollars per
extraordinary need Grant under the
additional 20 million per year so 11 and
12 are the old
three and four
I don't remember yes the old three and
four plus twenty mil a year right yeah
okay
comment yes
thank you Mr Chad
um
I have I have a question on the
procedure here so that
um we could keep
no no no
on the education trust fund
um the Surplus we have
on page six is 96 million is that
correct
correct and um so we can use the we can
we can use that 96 million and put some
of it into
um
the extraordinary needs account
and and still leave the 4700 in the
original
in the original
um base
is is that is that workable
for those two things so that's
essentially proposal 10 keeping forty
seven hundred twenty five hundred as the
governor recommended but increasing the
extraordinary needs up to 37.50 and
spending an additional 40 million over
the biennium yes where's the 37.50 the
extraordinary Grant okay and what is the
that's 20 million per year so 40 million
over the biennium more than the
governor's budget so that would come out
of this Surplus this is conceivably yes
yes barring no other changes so that's
where you are right now with changes to
date
so proposal 10 would increase the
adequacy adequate education
Appropriations by about 40 million over
the biennium so that 96 would be about
56.
well I mean that sounds like something
that would meet the the needs of of the
requirements that people were asking for
as far as increasing the
um
on the right hand side
um increasing the extraordinary needs
line
while still leaving the
while still leaving what most people are
going to see that the Baseline where at
the governor's recommended
and you can see on the the next page
the town by town so proposal number 10
is that that scenario there
so you see there is some more targeted
Aid to certain communities that wouldn't
get it under the governor's recommended
other towns get a little bit less
they were not ones dependent on
extraordinary needs and spends about 40
million over the biennium war
which is what looking at proposal 11 on
that 10. next page is that way numbers
I think if you look at Concord
you'll see where that extraordinary age
huh I know yeah
not even have my lighter fluid for tar
removal
are you happy with that
I'm saying I'm asking all those
questions and I and I don't
I don't see anything under proposal 11
for Conway
it was it wasn't a good idea
well I mean it's you're still getting
the same positions
well you're you're good no no
stabilization's gone in all these
proposals to hold harmless
old harmless
on a different
like decline schedule right
so even even proposal 10
is about a 59 million dollar hold
harmless has to still be in play and
representative I did Total the number of
towns that are well I didn't I don't
think I did it for these but for that
first block of scenarios that we did it
was I don't think any of the scenarios
Eclipse 100 towns as far as ones they
would get more money so essentially it
was in the 90s like let me see I can
pull it up
see I'll be happy to just write that
so in
let me see
well there's 103 towns under proposal 10
would get more money than under current
law so all of those figures you see
103 and then I guess doing math
242 or 142 are zeros
and I think we're two towns are zero no
change yeah and do you have those
numbers of tones for proposals three to
nine
um
and I'm really fine getting that answer
tomorrow morning too because I don't
think that we'll be making this decision
in the next 45 minutes
but it's just a number that I would like
to have when evaluating all these
proposals because of
non-policy but political considerations
speak to the government
and then so then it starts at 98 at
proposal three
then 94 91
87 81 79
74 and then proposal 9 is 73.
and the reason you see that taper is
as
as the the
as the left goes up and you have more
hold harmless on the right is what
happens or at left goes down rather we
yes thank
you thank you Mr Mickey
um in turn I just want to ask some
questions about Conway so Conway
um the
um 11 and 12 they don't see any funding
now my question is
North Conway and Conway are are pretty
affluent towns but those who live there
and do the day-to-day work
um
I don't know if you have a high fnr
and I was just wondering why they there
wouldn't be
how that balanced out if they have a
so they they have a decent F and r
so as you increase
bass and the fnr per pupil they they get
somebody that's why under the governors
they see an increase
however
they are not qualified for fiscal
capacity disparity Aid and they do have
a stabilization Grant so when you pull
the stabilization Grant away
and Target it with extraordinary needs
they don't get the extraordinary needs
but they lose the stabilization Grant
but they are close on stabilization that
when the
base and fnr is at the governor's levels
they would see an increase but when you
start tapering down the governors they
don't see an increase and
there's a lot of towns that would fall
on that boat there's there's probably
close to a half a dozen different
scenarios that could happen you know if
you put each other towns into certain
categories uh and that that's Conway's
Story and there's probably other towns
similar
Berlin is in the same position that it
gets
it looks like nothing I think is it
correct to say that the removal of the
stabilization Grant is really what
Berlin is going to feel the most
regardless of what we do on the right
side of the equation
absolutely so Berlin stabilization Grant
like is more than half of their total
adequacy plus swept so when you take
that away they're replacing it with a
Statewide uh equalized valuation per
pupil based extraordinary needs it does
not come close to offsetting the loss of
stabilization you'll see claremonts in
the same boat as a similarly so if I may
whoops so they have
Berlin has a ton of State Property
which they can't tax
and then they have high F and R numbers
and they still
it's for Berlin you're talking yeah yeah
so their stabilization Grant is five and
a half million dollars
their cost of an adequate education as
calculated through on the left side of
the point is less than that so their
stabilization is more than half of like
I said so they qualify but not remotely
close to how much the stabilization is
all right thank you so I can tell you
for so scenario 12 would be out of the
ones that we just did here with the
additional money
let me call that up and I'll tell you so
so under scenario 12
that's where our the fiscal capacity or
excuse me the extraordinary needs is
what eight eight thousand
right and even with the infusion of the
additional 20 million and lowering the
left side of the formula to send that
money targeted there's Statewide 118
million dollars for Extraordinary needs
3.5 is Berlin
so if you're taking away a five and a
half million dollar stabilization and
you're replacing it even with this most
targeted Aid proposal it's still 2
million short of replacing so their
and even the proposal 12 is about 46.5
million dollars Statewide of a hold
harmless so Berlin is 2 million of that
plus there's a bunch of other towns in
yes
so scenario 12
from from the governors or from um yeah
the governors yeah so the governor was
47 and 2500 proposal 12s 44 and 23 20.
okay thank you
foreign
proposal 10 11 and 12 they all account
for that extra 20 million over
for each year in the biennium for the
extraordinary needs Grant that's also
baked in right yeah okay yeah so if you
look at page two of this handout right
along the top the state total so you'll
see the governor recommended was about
120 million over the biennium above
current law these three proposals are
closer to 160. so that's where the extra
but then we would have to change the
language on there on the 50 percent
increase
so yeah so as what's in House Bill 2 now
the governor was keeping extraordinary
needs at 650 so adding 50 to that each
biennium would extrapolate out but if
you are going to increase to a number
you see here you'd probably want to
revisit that 50 increase or would
get pretty pretty large really quick
we're just doing the same thing quicker
uh yeah you're getting to your well the
extraordinary needs kids you're getting
to the extraordinary needs quicker and
then you're gonna decide how you want to
handle the whole harmless if you're
right
so can't we just say that this
application relies only for this
biennium
and that the
would um
the um
um
it is anyway yeah right right I mean if
not if we take the governor's scenario
going out 10 years yeah I mean you could
not do 10 years of changes and just
change it fiscal 24 and 25 and in each
year thereafter and then that's the
formula set and then it would be up to
Future changes if you wanted to go that
road but you need to as we mentioned
earlier today you can't just say for
fiscal 24 it's this way and fiscal 25 is
that way and then be silent on 26 and
Beyond you have to legislate something
but I would just be careful about using
the 50 increase if you do increase
extraordinary needs yeah it's not as
much a question as a reminder that
if we change the extraordinary needs
Grant we absolutely have to change those
percentages otherwise I'm gonna have to
vote no just because I can do the math
10 years down the road and I cannot
bypass any legislation regardless of how
much I know that it will be changed in
the future but I cannot vote Yes on
legislation that if allowed to go on for
yeah so an option is to Simply set the
rate if you decide to move the equalized
or the extraordinary needs to a certain
level and not and and have the two
percent for instance apply to that right
you know we we already talked about that
two percent uh adjustment applying to
the base Aid and the differentiated you
could apply it to that too so
it grows smaller and now the the 10-year
plan the governor's put forward is is
now a shorter plan and probably might
need to be Revisited in another
legislative session because we're
starting with a higher base starting
with a higher base you know and then the
question is how you'd want to handle the
whole harmless
but you could still keep that same pace
of reducing it by 20 for the next five
bienniums but you're not going to
increase the extraordinary needs at that
same Pace because you've already got it
pretty high
but that
you're I mean from what I I don't know
what the governor's total estimate for
fiscal 26 and 27
education funding is but yours would be
higher because you're
cranking that extraordinary needs a lot
sooner
so would you like to sleep on it
or you have a favorite
I just have one I just have another
question and it's probably the same
question I may have asked already in a
different form I don't know what the
extraordinary needs you're saying that
would
um we're going to be adding to it and is
that still coming from the Surplus the
education trust fund Surplus yeah
adequacies paid for the education trust
fund as far as surpluses and everything
goes right now as we've heard from
representative Weiler he will be
bringing forward an amendment for the
committee to consider that's going to
drastically change how you see the
education trust fund in the Surplus
statement so it is going to drastically
change it is going to drastically change
so what we're working with here is just
this 96. that's yeah as of right now
represent representative Weiler is
speaking about an amendment to shift all
kinds of revenues from the education
trust fund and programs to the general
fund
and that Surplus would likely follow so
and it would essentially become General
funds at that point and uh you know so
that and that Amendment hasn't really
thoroughly been uh offered yet to review
but that's the gist of what he's been
discussing
thank you some members of the committee
are of the opinion that you can't
transfer funds from the education trust
I think we can I think the only I mean
but it would take statutory change uh
right yes great the only the only thing
that's constitutionally protected is
Lottery Revenue has to go to public
schools and that's 158 million of the
1.2 billion dollar education trust fund
but the other revenues are subject to
statute RSA 198 39 whatever it is so you
can Define what goes into the education
trust fund and what it's used for and
those sections are actually already in
house bill 2. because as you recall the
governor's proposal added a couple
programs to the education trust fund
representative Weiler is talking about
removing those plus others to the
general fund as well as a lot of Revenue
yes yeah I have I just would like to go
over a narrative a little bit to
understand a little more what's going on
here in terms of the schools that are
more well often the schools that aren't
so no one is no one's going to end up
with less money uh with what we're doing
everyone's going to get something it's
just a magnitude of what and so I was
looking at yeah in the next two years
um
in the governor's regular with Deerfield
with proposal 10 it goes up 10 it goes
up a little bit and in proposal 11 it
goes down about by half and proposal 12
it goes down by half again and I'm
attributing that to there's lesser need
in the Deerfield area than there are in
other places and I was comparing that to
Concord which is in another League
anyway but the governor's regular is the
three
and then with the proposal 10
that boosts up to seven uh seven I guess
million proposal 11 and proposal 12 both
brings it up close to nine and close to
ten and this is reflective of the
greater need in Concord
so I guess I'm
coming back to the thing everyone has an
increase everything is everyone's going
to be a little bit better off and the
differences that I'm seeing between
proposal 10 11 and 12
the larger numbers going up reflect
greater need in the schools and the
numbers where it's going down reflect
schools that are probably doing okay and
you know I looked quickly at Newcastle
there's like no change you know there's
nothing for us to do there but I think
um
when I'm thinking of this I'm trying to
keep in mind that every school is going
to get an increase and if our goal is to
get more funding towards the programs
that really need it
um
11 and 12 are perhaps better than that
12 maybe goes is asking maybe too much
and 11 is
you know perhaps a little I don't know
11 is somewhere between 10 and 12
obviously but I'm trying to say I'm
trying to just really focus on if we
said that we wanted to get money to
schools that have greater need then I
need to look at this information with
yes Dan just wanted to state that I
appreciated discussion is more about 10
11 12 because that's the new information
in front of the committee but I do want
to point out that you know three to nine
are still on the table too and uh you
know when we make decisions probably
tomorrow all of those are on the table
but indeed this is the time to analyze
did you catch the drift of what we did
I just wanted you to be clued in because
what we did is we added 20 million
dollars in each fiscal year
uh to be distributed through
is the and it's probably a question for
you Mickey but uh is is the 20 million
dollars what's boosting the
extraordinary needs in proposal 10 so
it's bringing it from 650 to
3750. okay
and
I mean that I I think we defer to the
legislature on where the additional
funding goes I think we our position is
still that we believe that the
governor's recommended is is the most
appropriate for what everyone's trying
to achieve balancing all the interests
however
um if if you're intending to add
additional funding you know proposal 10
looks looks interesting I I'd have to
study it a little bit more but
um but that's that's kind of where I
so does anybody have any other questions
before you go home and dream about this
again can I ask Tom representative Buco
a question
um you know under the under let's look
at proposal 10 because I'm kind of
leaning towards
um adding the money for the the right
side of the formula so under proposal 10
uh there's an additional 359. I'm in
Conway sorry incense since
representative bucco's here well you
mentioned Conway so you're around 12
million dollars is this my um do I have
enough zeros here or is it 12 million
yes okay so your 12 million dollars in
Conway
um the regular Governors recommended is
351 000 uh proposal 10 which adds a
little bit to the right side gets you
359 000. 11 and 12 get enough there's
not you don't get an additional thing
there right right I'm sorry looking
right below there's Cornish
which is a 2 million and under
the governor's 10 11 12.
there's no increase for them okay so
what I'm asking is
because Conway is in pretty good shape
you have a good budget you can support
your budget
how hard is it to for you to go like
proposal 11 to try to explain that to
your people it's it's a matter of you
know 350 000 which is not
Hue it's it's money it's a lot of money
but it's not huge compared to your 12
million dollar school budget
um that you know I'm asking because you
you brought up the question what do I
say to my people so could can you
explain to your people say proposal 11
that we put in money for Extraordinary
well I keep saying I guess the
extraordinary needs is the best way to
describe it or the right side of the
formula and Conway is affluent enough
not to need that so I mean how do you
talk to your constituents giving that if
you want 11 and 12 you would not get an
increase
um well anything that anything that
takes away and increase is not going to
be
um
acceptable acceptable and
there is no take away you would still
get the 12 million three hundred and
fifteen thousand there's no loss there's
just not and little increase but there's
no loss that's the that's um the
adequacy is the 12 million is that right
because that's that's not the total the
um
I don't know I mean I asked that
question because that's what we normally
what what happens if there's anything
taken away I you know you go home and
they say you you
've already watching it to probably
right now and um you know they say that
you know you voted for something that
took money away from us
it didn't take anything away it just
didn't add but it did not right it
didn't add but it did not take away and
it didn't add because you don't have the
needs that other communities do okay I
assume where you're going now thank you
thank you does can does that make is
that a story you can tell that would be
comfortable for your constituents
yes I think so but the other thing is
they're they're not going to see this
you know we're looking at comparative
data they're not going to see comparison
well
okay so what what representative Heath
is saying that is the 47 still stays and
that's what that's
and yes
and that's what people see that's what
they're going to see so if that stays
that
oh yeah I know
Mr chair
um I appreciate you know all these
projections all of them assume that we
are gonna take the governor's funding as
recommended or we're gonna add you know
significant amounts
I'm still stressed by the fact that we
don't really know whether we can go
forward with even the governor's
proposal as is which I would hope we can
but since I don't know that for a fact
would it be appropriate to ask me to
Mickey to prepare a couple of
scenarios where we may need to cut a
little from the adequacy or is the view
of the committee that that is in
absolutely not the possibility and we
don't want to spend stuff time on it we
have it to spend that's not a question
okay so this is not the question that's
perfectly for I'm asking because I want
to be prepared for every possibility
the I'm not sure what the possibilities
are but I will uh here you know I got it
well between yeah between this
and this are really what the
possibilities I am
um one separate question if I may it's a
follow-up to this if I could really
quickly separate question one of the
things that uh chairman land who's uh
here uh was asking um at the beginning
of the lunch break was the possibility
of maybe putting more money in the
special education that's a left side you
know
um and I was wondering if we would maybe
consider a scenario similar to scenarios
three to nine where instead of you know
putting money into the extraordinary
needs Grant we could run an analysis on
what happens if we take a little bit
from the base and put it into the
special education just trying to cover
contingencies I don't want to waste
anybody's time if this is something the
committee will absolutely not consider
but I just want to ask and know what our
options are at this time I've got 11
different we've got 11 different
yes I think also representative Ladd was
very clear that
um the increase in sped is not going to
Target property poor communities because
we all understand that special education
is not zip code dependent and that you
know everyone shares equally in special
education needs across the state
and there are everybody's getting more
I'm going to change lanes real quick
we've been having uh our meetings are
being observed and we had a call from
unh
about making they were con unclear what
our position was on the 8 million
dollars for
I just lost it yes so Whittemore Center
is an open item we have and they do have
one pending request they're business
Partnerships with Keene State and
Plymouth States a five million dollar
request they can be available at 10
o'clock tomorrow morning to just answer
any questions that come up to just I
think this Committee just needs to
decide on those two items probably
sooner than later so uh
um Kathy provencher and uh president
Dean can be here tomorrow at 10 o'clock
to discuss if is that necessary or
I
I think some of us at any rate are
really in favor of some of those
proposals but the problem is we don't
know how much money we have to spend in
general funds
um so I know we're going to be going
through a I hope a few more things on
this sheet so we know kind of where we
are in terms of General funds but that's
the problem I think we all want to be
able to support the university system
Plymouth and Keane both have some needs
as well and they didn't ask they only
asked for uh they only they asked for
five million dollars oh for the across
the biennium
um so we have neglected our University
system schools and our community
colleges so if we can do something for
them I'm all for it well I think the
question is because the Whittemore
Center is coming out of uh Surplus
is there is we don't know where we are
because everybody's spending the Surplus
we've probably spent it twice so far so
similarly yes precisely three divisions
meeting right now and it's ever changing
um and we're still waiting for some
guidance some bigger picture guidance of
some budget targets uh but as far as
this this division can proceed at any
time to re-purpose or re-prioritize some
of the Appropriations that were before
you for instance if you wanted to reduce
Whittemore by x amount and add that X to
a different thing you can do that
without worrying about the other
divisions as far as just adds to that we
just need to be careful a little bit how
much we do and we just want to
communicate that
so my I I guess what I'm trying to get
to is do we want is there a need to have
them come or it's really a question of
do we have the funds to spend and right
now we're allocating it for the
Whittemore Center and it's really if you
need if the committee feels you need any
more information from UNH I know we've
had them in a couple times to talk about
these items but they are available if
you feel you do need them back
what's the feeling of the board I got a
question
right uh can I come out of the uh
I did it's it's very bright very bright
let me tell you this is uh I'm in I'm in
Spotlight unfortunately can we take that
uh with a more Center out of the
education trust fund
so again statutorily you can write
anything into the education trust fund
but your chair has an amendment to pull
all that education trust fund money away
so right if we take the 40 million out
all right we've still got another 46 uh
no 56. the chair has talked about taking
all of that Surplus to the general fund
oh he's going to sweep it yes so that's
that's the discussion we don't have it
to spend anymore unless we spend it as
I would just recommend coordination with
chairwyler this is stuff he's discussed
online and offline so so we should we
should consider the other five million
not out of surplus but out of Education
I I'm going to ask I'll defer to what
the committee wants to do in
communication with the chair and others
and we can talk about that tomorrow
I mean we this is a short decision yeah
just one quick thing when ccsnh was here
this morning one of the reasons why they
were able to get the requests approved
was that they brought us updated numbers
that were lower now I don't really
expect that for waiter more and I'm not
sure if that would be something that
would be applicable to the 5 million
but you know if that's a possibility
that I would definitely want to hear
that from you know straight from the
horse's mouth as it were that you know
maybe a smaller amount maybe appropriate
or not I mean to me those are the kind
of conversations that would help overall
I think we've already heard the
presentation as I don't think we need
them for just repeating what was already
said but if they do have new stuff it
would
however I don't think you think
um
we haven't been given guidance in terms
of you know what our parameters would be
I would be in favor of just supporting
it all and saying yeah we do want to
support this and if it comes down the
pike later on they're saying well sorry
you know we should have let you know you
didn't have that money to begin with I
think it's still a statement to say I'm
I'm I support these ideas I'm trying to
work really hard to figure out what the
budget and what the parameters are but
if I'm not given that direction as to
interoperability
and the Whittemore Center
no I think the the
five million they're talking about
you know those those are strong programs
and they do pay for themselves I think
in the long run around Workforce
um
I guess I'm certainly support the
concept of it I'd be glad to support it
I could see supporting that at half the
request
it looks like it's only uh 2025 if I'm
correct
oh you're right yes yes okay
Dan
it would be much more likely to vote in
favor of such things tomorrow after we
would have an update from all the other
divisions and the summary and everything
I'm just sharing that honestly I want to
support these things but I cannot do it
at this point in time because of the
huge uncertainty over how much the
bottom line how far we are from the
bottom line so if if you guys want to
vote right now we can vote right now but
tomorrow would be probably more
productive as a vote
so I agree with you I think you know
about
um my where you're being cautious to say
you want to wait I'm saying since we
have to make a decision and these things
yes
I'm moving into the spotlight here good
night
certainly I'm certainly not going to
speak on behalf of the trustees but I am
a trustee for the University system of
New Hampshire
and I would
I would absolutely when you get an offer
from Jim Dean who's the academic
Chancellor before both Keane Plymouth
State and UNH and with Kathy provencher
to come in I think 15 20 minutes of them
tomorrow would really be a benefit to
you where you can Grill down through
some of these questions you've been just
asking now
okay
well by dividing things in half and
doing this and that and we might ask
okay what's that going to do over there
at the biggest problem is if
representative Weiler is saying that
he's going to sweep the education trust
and the 96 million dollars we've been
talking about we need to know that
um if you could put a date of 25 on it
then we could continue as we're working
um so he would do it in a future
biennium not this biennium because it's
we're going to have to go back and sort
through what's general fund now and
unless well as you said Mickey I think
we can make the 96 million dollars go
away which means the 40 million that we
just put into this formula might be
I think his intention
the net net of his intention is to
reduce the inflows
okay
I I don't remember saying anything about
sweeping anything I think what he was
talking about was reducing the inflows
so that it starts moving down towards
what base adequacy is all about
so and that's
you know that's what we have okay then
very quickly I do not plan to adjust my
votes on spending based on whether the
funding is from the
fund or from the general funds whether
it's from the trust fund on the general
fund the priorities remain the same to
me so to me that whole thing is just a
matter of which pocket stuff is coming
from it doesn't change my bottom line it
doesn't change my spending so if we vote
to support something because it's coming
from the trust fund and then we change
the way the money goes in the trust fund
I will absolutely vote for that to go
back to the general fund you know it's
it it shouldn't change what we budget
for this in this budget so
what we have is the 96 million that's in
this trust fund Surplus statement
we don't have anything that says sweep
no and if he unless he comes in and says
that we have this if he comes in and
says I'm sweeping well then we don't
have anything anyway then then our whole
budget goes to hell so I don't know if
that's going to be the answer so we'll
find out and I think he needs to bring
that proposal in so what that would do
is just move the education trust funds
to General funds but that doesn't mean
they couldn't still be spent as general
funds at that point so right so yeah you
know so
I ideally
this amendment would be
communicated and brought forward and
clear what is going on but I can just
say that at this point that discussion
has been made that he's he's working on
something and
I'm starting to feel like we're probably
not going to get a whole lot done today
that's kind of my feeling right now I
think we've done all we're going to do
um
yeah
I think some of these smaller things
you'd probably be okay with if you
support them so for instance so go to
page three
there's a couple I don't know there's
Department of Safety has brought forward
the request for a lot of new positions
here that were additional prioritized
needs right through their agency budget
request did not make it into the
governor's recommended budget so they
were communicated here just as an
example if you look at the homeland
security and emergency management
position on lines three through six it's
only 112 000 General funds if this is a
something that the committee supports
and it's a priority of this committee
and you support the request you could
probably make a change like that and not
have to worry about blowing up the
budget with 100 which line was that so
why is three through six
my issue with that though this this is
an executive branch
and if the governor didn't want it I
don't know the and that's and that's a
reasonable way to look at these two that
they with the governor's spending levels
and and priorities these didn't make
there so they were communicated to you
as customary that these are additional
prioritizing these that were not in the
governors I don't think there's any
requirement that that you support them
either they were just brought forward to
your cons for your consideration
uh as far as there's nothing on here
that I'm looking at that I you know I'm
looking at that you need to do this for
because there's a house bill 2 section
or this law this bill is out there these
are purely just brought forward to you
as funding requests and they're up to
okay well I
somewhere uh we're totaling this up
so at some point if somebody's gonna hit
the total button and say well we've
triple spent it
the total button could get pressed and
you realize you're dipping into the
rainy day fund to balance your budget or
it could get pressed of say you're
spending you're sending you know another
80 million to the rainy day fund maybe
you only want to spend 60 do you want to
do something with a 20. I don't have
those numbers here right now I don't
well one thing to look at with um what
three four and five where we are right
now is that some of that money I guess
it's federal funds and then there's
other funds which is not specified but
that's not a big ask from the general
fund and I'm always fond of money that's
matched from someplace else so what item
are you looking at um the safety the
homeland security emergencies at
management line three four five and then
it's totaled on six so you know what
they're looking for the general fund is
a hundred and twelve thousand over the
two years matched by the federal and
then another 96 coming from other
so you know that's other money that's
that's there
um presumably would it go away if we
didn't match it is often a question
yeah so I'm I'm support funds when it's
when there's other funds coming into it
and this is just up to the committee if
you want to establish two new positions
too so there's a policy point of view
there's there's dollars associated with
it but then it's creating two new
uh Folks at Homeland Security and
Emergency Management so that's an
example and you don't even have to force
votes today if you're not feeling like
you're in a place to do them I was just
bringing that up as an example of
there's a couple items on here that
aren't huge dollars it's more of a do
support that request or not
yes honestly when I look at that whole
block of safety requests the one that I
remember being more uh
you know struck by is a priority is the
number of criminalists in the forensic
lab where everything is delayed by a
mile those are not federally matched but
I would argue that Federal match or not
you know to me that seems like a bigger
priority than the you know HSA hsem
positions and
it's yeah well let's just say that in
about 28 hours or so we should be
well we know what the
what the votes are going to be tomorrow
so so think about it
with column are you
most
likely for
I know I know where I am
to me the the big decisions for this
committee are still the adequacy like
you said Mr chairman School building Aid
and then policy with the education trust
fund those are and I'm tracking those as
the three biggest things remaining
everything else here is they're there
but it's not quite as important as those
three so those are the ones I'm gonna
really push that we settle on tomorrow
okay
say again 10. yeah
with the additional 40 million Oh I
thought you meant we start at 10.
Oh I thought you were asking me what
time we start tomorrow so no I'm I'm in
yes and I think to Tom's Point that's
kind of like that's the number
everybody's been hearing and so if we
deviate from that I think the torn
feather come back out that's my concern
so that's that's where I am but that's
not necessarily where the vote's gonna
go afterwards you're going to get salt
bring your voting pin tomorrow because
or your
voting Voice or whatever
because we will be voting these out
tomorrow
thank you for your work Mickey welcome
we'll get through one more day and we'll
uh and it's tomorrow posted or I just
read just uh recess uh recess everything
to this point we're you can put in
recess but we are scheduled to reconvene
tomorrow okay so we'll recess this works
oh I know that
I understand that but right now it's 30